And welcome to your second drink of employee transfer. This is the episode where Michael and Daryl and Holly drive to Nashua and Pam goes out to lunch with Jim and his brothers. We got some really great insider tidbits from the writer of this episode, Anthony Farrell, and from actor Tug Coker and Angela, you do a very excellent breakdown of Halloween costumes from the cold open because we had our little Halloween cold open in this one. I mean, I love them all, the work that went into that moment. And you guys wrote in and told us your favorite employee transfer moments, and almost everyone mentioned the same scene. Brianna E. from Illinois, Tanish from India, and Kelly from Sterling said, my favorite scene in this episode, and honestly, one of my all-time favorite scenes is when Holly, Michael, and Daryl are in the car, and Holly starts crying, and Michael asks Daryl if he touched her. It gets me every time. Daryl's reaction is the best. I mean, all of the scenes of them driving are so great. And there's that classic blooper that plays, too, where the, like, the process car driver that the truck was like hitched to starts to drive away before they're ready and they all start laughing. I know the three of them had the best time in that car. It's such good stuff. It's such good stuff. And, you know, I look back on our show and there's so many people who I thought deserved an Emmy. And Craig,
欢迎收听第二杯《员工调动》。这一集讲述了迈克尔、达里尔和霍莉开车前往纳舒厄，而帕姆则和吉姆及其兄弟们一起去吃午餐。我们从本集编剧安东尼·法雷尔和演员塔格·科克那里得到了一些非常棒的内幕消息，而且安吉拉，你对冷开场中的万圣节服装做了非常精彩的解析，因为我们这一集里有一个小小的万圣节冷开场。我是说，我喜欢所有的服装，为了那一刻所付出的努力。你们写信告诉了我们你们最喜欢的《员工调动》时刻，几乎每个人都提到了同一个场景。来自伊利诺伊州的布里安娜·E、来自印度的塔尼什和来自斯特林的凯利说，我这一集里最喜欢的场景，老实说，也是我个人有史以来最喜欢的场景之一，就是霍莉、迈克尔和达里尔在车里，霍莉开始哭，迈克尔问达里尔是不是碰了她。每次看我都感动。达里尔的反应是最棒的。我是说，他们开车的所有场景都太棒了。还有一个经典的NG镜头，就是那个拖着卡车的“过程车”司机在他们还没准备好时就开始开车，他们都笑了起来。我知道他们三个人在车里玩得很开心。这真是太棒了。这真是太棒了。而且，你知道，我回顾我们的剧集，有很多人我觉得他们值得获得艾美奖。而克雷格，
Robinson is one of them. All of his reactions when Michael and Holly are having really personal conversations and he's stuck right there in a three-seat truck. Yes. Oh, brilliant acting. And then we also got a note from Teus C from Brazil and Nicole S from Hagerstown, Maryland, who said that they love an extended scene from the Peacock Superfan version where Daryl talks to Michael about cow surfing. It's pretty amazing. Let me set it up for you. Holly, Michael and Daryl, they're on the road. Holly has like one of those cats cradles. You know how you do the string in your fingers? On your fingers and you make the pattern. Yes. And her and Michael, they're kind of laughing about it. They're kind of being in their own world. And Daryl's like, am I on a road trip alone? Or are we all three on a road trip? But here's what he tells Michael about cows. Let's hear it. Am I grabbing this one? No, that's not what you're grabbing.
罗宾逊就是其中之一。当迈克尔和霍莉进行非常私人的谈话时，他被困在三座卡车里，他所有的反应都太棒了。是的。哦，精彩的表演。然后我们还收到了来自巴西的特斯·C和马里兰州黑格斯敦的妮可·S的来信，他们说他们喜欢孔雀超级粉丝版中一个加长场景，达里尔和迈克尔谈论“奶牛冲浪”。这太神奇了。让我为你铺垫一下。霍莉、迈克尔和达里尔在路上。霍莉玩着那种翻绳游戏。你知道怎么用手指玩绳子吗？在手指上做出图案。是的。她和迈克尔对此笑个不停。他们好像沉浸在自己的世界里。达里尔说，我是独自在公路旅行吗？还是我们三个人在公路旅行？但这就是他告诉迈克尔关于奶牛的事。让我们听听。是我要抢这个吗？不，那不是你要抢的。
Okay. Hey, y'all not gonna be playing these little private games all we? Sorry, Darrow. Same driving as Daisy, you know. You gotta include me in the conversation. Fair enough. You don't mind. Okay. Okay.
好吧。嘿，你们俩不会一直玩这些私人的小游戏吧？抱歉，达里尔。开车和戴西一样，你知道的。你得让我参与谈话。有道理。你不介意吧。好吧。好吧。
What kind of car games do you play in the hood? I got a game. Cow surfing. Cow surfing? It's by the cow. Last person to say Jackson 5 has to get on his back and ride it. Really? There are even cows where you grow up? Everybody got a government cow. Cow surfing.
你们在街区玩什么车内游戏？我有一个游戏。奶牛冲浪。奶牛冲浪？就是奶牛。最后一个说“杰克逊五人组”的人必须爬到它背上骑着它。真的吗？你长大的地方甚至有奶牛吗？每个人都有政府发的奶牛。奶牛冲浪。
Okay, here we go. There's a cow. Jackson Five. So! Shoot! Okay. All right. All right.
好吧，开始了。有一头奶牛。杰克逊五人组。所以！该死！好吧。好了。好了。
Pull it over. Here we go. Go get it, Mike. I'm gonna do it. Michael, it's not a real game. Then why did you say Jackson Five? That's the man at his point. Daryl.
靠边停车。开始了。去抓住它，迈克。我要去做了。迈克尔，那不是真正的游戏。那你为什么要说“杰克逊五人组”？这就是重点，达里尔。
I hear that made a minute. What? Why? So I wanted you to like me. I do. Hey, come on. Dax are five. So I just love this whole dynamic.
我听到了，等一下。什么？为什么？所以我想要你喜欢我。我喜欢。嘿，来吧。杰克逊五人组。所以我就是喜欢这种动态。
It just brings out some of my favorite, like, little character, nuance relationships of all these people, of just how, like, Holly is willing to be just as silly with Michael, but also she's not as gullible, you know? And so she has to be like, Michael. Yeah, she's like, Michael, no, honey. And then Michael is always asking Daryl about life in the hood. and then Daryl makes stuff up and Michael believes it. Right. I just love all of it. I would have watched more of them in a car together, the three of them.
它展现了我最喜欢的一些小角色，这些人的细微关系，比如霍莉愿意和迈克尔一起犯傻，但她又没那么容易上当，你知道吗？所以她不得不说，迈克尔。是的，她说，迈克尔，不，亲爱的。然后迈克尔总是问达里尔关于街区生活的事，达里尔就编造一些东西，迈克尔还信了。对吧。我就是喜欢这一切。我本来想看更多他们三个人在车里的戏份。
Yeah. Yeah. I'd watch a whole 30 minutes of that. We do. All right. Well, everybody, thanks again for writing in your favorite moments. We love hearing them. You can submit them at office ladies.com over at our second drinks folder.
是啊。是啊。我会看整整30分钟那样的内容。我们会的。好了，各位，再次感谢你们写信告诉我们你们最喜欢的时刻。我们喜欢听这些。你们可以在officeladies.com的“第二杯”文件夹中提交。
But now it's time for our second drink of employee transfer. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies.
但现在是时候喝我们的第二杯《员工调动》了。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。
Da-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-da. Oh, Michael. Michael. Bless his heart. You guys, today, it's employee transfer. It is season five, episode six, written by Anthony Farrell and director. by Dave Rogers. We have lots to say.
哒-那-那-那-那-那-那-那-那-那-哒。哦，迈克尔。迈克尔。上帝保佑他。伙计们，今天，是《员工调动》。这是第五季第六集，由安东尼·法雷尔编剧，戴夫·罗杰斯导演。我们有很多话要说。
There's a really good DVD commentary. I didn't do any deep dives, though. What? I'm sorry in advance for anyone who likes them, and you're welcome to the people who hate them. I might need a minute. No deep dives. I have a summary. I know you have a summary and fast facts, but we also reached out to a ton of people,
有一个非常好的DVD评论。不过我没有做任何深度挖掘。什么？我提前向任何喜欢深度挖掘的人道歉，也欢迎那些讨厌它们的人。我可能需要一分钟。没有深度挖掘。我有一个总结。我知道你有总结和速记事实，但我们也联系了很多人，
so we have lots of good trivia. We did. That is very true. I will give you my summary. Do it. Pam is embarrassed when. And no one else at corporate wears a costume on Halloween. That is the worst.
所以我们有很多好的花絮。我们确实做了。这是千真万确的。我会给你我的总结。说吧。帕姆很尴尬，因为公司里没有其他人穿万圣节服装。那是最糟糕的。
It was so funny. It was so funny to do, and it gets me every time. Holly and Michael deal with Holly's transfer to the Nashua branch. Remember when David Wallace last week saw them kissing after the auction? Yeah. Yeah. He was like, I'm not having another Jan and Michael on my hands. No, no depositions.
太搞笑了。做起来太搞笑了，每次都让我感动。霍莉和迈克尔处理霍莉调往纳舒厄分部的事。还记得上周大卫·华莱士看到他们在拍卖会后接吻吗？是啊。是啊。他当时说，我可不想再处理一对简和迈克尔了。不，不，不要再有证词了。
Not on my watch. I know. Also, Dwight tries to get under Andy's skin by applying to Cornell. I love that storyline. Same. And finally, Pam is going to team up with Jim's brothers to play a prank on Jim. Telling you, those Halberts and the pranks. You know how I feel about pranks. I know how you feel about them in real life. The same as how I feel about tickling. I know, but Pam is like, sign me up. Let's prank away. I know. Pam loves a prank. That's why Pam married Jim. That's right. Jenna would not marry Jim. No, because there'd be too much pranking. All right, fast fact number one. New writer alert, Anthony Farrell. Yeah. Anthony was with us for season five. He is a writer and a comedian. This was the first episode that he wrote for the show, but I didn't know this until I looked it up. The first thing he wrote was actually the Kevin's Lone webisodes. That's right. He wrote a series of webisodes. And some of
在我眼皮底下不行。我知道。还有，德怀特试图通过申请康奈尔大学来激怒安迪。我喜欢那个故事情节。我也是。最后，帕姆要和吉姆的兄弟们联手对吉姆搞恶作剧。跟你说，那些哈尔伯特一家和恶作剧。你知道我对恶作剧的看法。我知道你在现实生活中对它们的看法。和我对挠痒痒的看法一样。我知道，但帕姆就像是，算我一个。让我们开始恶作剧吧。我知道。帕姆喜欢恶作剧。这就是为什么帕姆嫁给了吉姆。没错。珍娜才不会嫁给吉姆。不，因为会有太多的恶作剧。好了，速记事实第一条。新编剧警报，安东尼·法雷尔。是啊。安东尼在第五季和我们在一起。他是一位编剧和喜剧演员。这是他为该剧写的第一集，但我直到查了才知道。他写的第一件事实际上是《凯文的孤独》网络剧。没错。他写了一系列网络剧。我们的一些编剧
our writers got to break off and do that. I would have loved to done that. I would have loved to written a webisode. I feel like you had a lot of freedom on the webisodes. Yeah, you did. They were pretty fun, which reminds me, we should break down the webisodes sometime. I mean, you don't even have to make it into a question. We definitely should. The accountants, the webisodes won an Emmy. An Emmy! I'm so jealous that you have an actual Emmy. I know, lady. In your house. I know. It's very pointy. Yeah, those wings are pointy. It's pointy. Angela, do you want to share that we got in touch with Anthony? Yes, we were emailing with Anthony.
有机会分出来做那个。我本来很想做那个。我本来很想写一集网络剧。我觉得你在网络剧上有很大的自由度。是啊，确实。它们很有趣，这让我想起，我们应该找时间解析一下网络剧。我是说，你甚至不需要把它变成一个问题。我们绝对应该。会计师，网络剧赢得了艾美奖。艾美奖！我真嫉妒你有一个真正的艾美奖。我知道，女士。在你家里。我知道。它很尖。是啊，那些翅膀很尖。它很尖。安吉拉，你想分享一下我们联系上了安东尼吗？是的，我们和安东尼发邮件。
We had the wrong email. Aaron sure to the rescue. Thank you, Erin. Thank you, Erin. Got us in touch. It was so great to reconnect with him. He and his family are back in Toronto, where he's from, and they're doing awesome. He shared with me that he is the showrunner for a show called the Parker Anderson's slash
我们弄错了邮箱。艾琳·舒尔来救场了。谢谢你，艾琳。谢谢你，艾琳。让我们联系上了。能和他重新联系上真是太好了。他和他的家人回到了多伦多，那是他的家乡，他们过得很好。他告诉我他是《帕克·安德森》斜杠
Amelia Parker. And it's actually two shows about the same characters from two different perspectives. I love that. It's so cool. He shared a lot of stuff with us. We're going to sprinkle it through the episode. But one of the things he said was before he got the office, he was a comedian, but he still needed that day job. And he was working at countrywide home loans. And he was so excited when he got the job as writer on the office because it meant he could quit countrywide home loans. He quit like the day before he started in the writer's room, right? Something crazy. Yeah, he was working at countrywide home loans. And then literally like the next. day was like, I'm going to go right now on a TV show. But all of that experience paid off because he was often called on in the writer's room to pitch like those very minutia office space storylines. And he sent us in audio clips. We'll share those and some other trivia he gave us. It's interesting because actually not a lot of our writers had real office work experience.
《阿米莉亚·帕克》的剧集主管。这实际上是关于同一角色的两部剧，从两个不同的视角出发。我喜欢这个。太酷了。他分享了很多东西。我们会在这一集中穿插讲述。但他说的其中一件事是，在得到《办公室》之前，他是一名喜剧演员，但他仍然需要那份日常工作。他在Countrywide房屋贷款公司工作。当他得到《办公室》编剧的工作时，他非常兴奋，因为这意味着他可以辞掉Countrywide的工作。他在开始编剧室工作的前一天辞职了，对吧？有些疯狂。是啊，他在Countrywide工作。然后字面意思上第二天就说，我要去写一部电视剧了。但所有的经验都得到了回报，因为他经常在编剧室被要求推销那些非常细致的办公室空间故事情节。他给我们发了音频片段。我们会分享这些以及他给我们的其他花絮。这很有趣，因为实际上我们很多编剧并没有真正的办公室工作经验。
So he was a fine. This was awesome to have him in there. Great perspective. All right, fast fact number two, new director alert. Yes, our very own Dave Rogers. Our editor. Yeah. If you guys haven't listened to his extended interview in our revisited episode, you should check it out because he is an amazing person and knows so much about the show. I dare say, I don't know if anyone else knows the show as well as him. You should dare to say that.
所以他是一个发现。有他在那里真是太棒了。很棒的视角。好了，速记事实第二条，新导演警报。是的，我们自己的戴夫·罗杰斯。我们的剪辑师。是啊。如果你们还没听过他在我们重温剧集中的加长采访，你们应该去看看，因为他是一个了不起的人，对这部剧了解得太多了。我敢说，我不知道还有谁像他一样了解这部剧。你应该敢说。
I dare say it then. Say it. I dare say it. She said it. I said it. We were also able to get in touch with Dave. He shared with me that he was so nervous to direct. Very excited, but he had a ton of anxiety.
那我敢说。说吧。我敢说。她说出来了。我说出来了。我们也联系上了戴夫。他告诉我他非常紧张去执导。非常兴奋，但他有很多焦虑。
He said he had a panic attack the night before filming, but he just pushed through. I was really curious, like, what the most challenging thing was coming from editing and then directing. Oh, that's a good question. He said the toughest thing about this episode was that there were so many locations. There were these multiple storylines. Michael had this huge emotional journey to go on. Yeah. And a physical journey.
他说他在拍摄前一天晚上恐慌发作，但他还是坚持了下来。我很好奇，从剪辑转到导演，最具挑战性的是什么。哦，这是个好问题。他说这一集最难的是地点太多了。有多个故事情节。迈克尔要经历一段巨大的情感旅程。是啊。还有一段身体旅程。
Yes. He said that the most challenging thing for him was just the pace of shooting. And he said it's like there's one thing if you have a ton of scenes in the bullpen and you have to make your day. But it's a whole other thing. If after you finish a scene, you have to pick up the entire crew and all the gear and move to another place and reset up because that eats up so much of your on-camera. shoot times. Yeah. But he did feel that coming from editing gave him an advantage because he just
是的。他说对他来说最具挑战性的是拍摄节奏。他说如果你在办公区有很多场景，你必须完成当天的任务，那是一回事。但如果你拍完一个场景，你必须带上整个剧组和所有装备搬到另一个地方重新设置，那是另一回事，因为那会占用你太多的摄像时间。是啊。但他确实觉得从剪辑转过来给了他优势，因为他
knew inherently the kind of stuff that got used on the show. He had watched so many directors do shots that were just never going to make it in. Right. So he said he was able to be really, really efficient. And he got to edit this episode. Oh, that's great, because how hard would it be as an editor to then direct and then give it away? I know, right? Yeah, I would think. He said that Dean Holland assembled a few scenes, and then Dave took over, and he did a full assembly. He did like a director's cut, and he said not much changed. I doubt it. And he was really, really proud that basically it was his director's cut that went to air. Nice. Well, I have more stuff from Dave, too, so we can share that. My fast fact number three is fun facts about Nashua. Let's hear them. I mean, Holly has to go live in
天生就知道剧里会用到什么样的素材。他看过太多导演拍的镜头根本没用上。对。所以他说他能够非常非常高效。而且他负责剪辑这一集。哦，那太好了，因为作为剪辑师然后执导，然后再把它交出去有多难？我知道，对吧？是啊，我会这么想。他说迪恩·霍兰德组装了几个场景，然后戴夫接手，他做了一个完整的组装。他做了一个导演剪辑版，他说没怎么变。我怀疑。而且他非常非常自豪，基本上是他的导演剪辑版播出了。不错。好吧，我还有更多戴夫的东西，所以我们可以分享。我的速记事实第三条是关于纳舒厄的趣事。让我们听听。我是说，霍莉必须去
Nashua. Don't we want to know more about it? I do. Good. I'm going to tell you. Okay. Holly is lucky because Nashua was named the best place to live in America two times in an annual survey by Money Magazine, and it is the only city to ever win that ranking twice. Holy crap, Nashua. It was in 1987 and 1998. Going strong at the end of the 90s.
纳舒厄生活。我们不想多了解一下吗？我想。很好。我会告诉你的。好吧。霍莉很幸运，因为纳舒厄在《金钱》杂志的年度调查中两次被评为美国最适合居住的地方，它是唯一一个两次获得该排名的城市。天哪，纳舒厄。那是在1987年和1998年。90年代末依然强劲。
Really? What else you got? Russian dressing. Originated in Nashua? Yeah. The salad dressing, Russian dressing. No. What?
真的吗？你还有什么？俄罗斯调料。起源于纳舒厄？是啊。沙拉酱，俄罗斯调料。不。什么？
You said you didn't have any deep dives. You were fooling. This is a mini deep dive on Nashua. Okay, you're right. It kind of is. And also on Russian dressing. It was created by a grocer named James Colburn. He started mixing it up.
你说你没有任何深度挖掘。你在骗人。这是一个关于纳舒厄的迷你深度挖掘。好吧，你说得对。确实有点像。还有关于俄罗斯调料。它是由一个叫詹姆斯·科尔伯恩的杂货商创造的。他开始混合它。
It looks like around 1910. Okay. And he started selling it at his grocery store under the name Colburn's mayonnaise salad dressing. Well, that's not a catchy title, so I can see why they had to jizz it up. Soon, he started Mani. manufacturing it on a bigger scale and shipping it around to other places. And he got so rich that he was able to retire. Whoa. In 1924. Wow. So just 14 years of selling this salad dressing. And he was like, peace out. Should we make a salad dressing? What's our salad dressing? What would be in it?
看起来是在1910年左右。好吧。他开始在他的杂货店以“科尔伯恩蛋黄酱沙拉酱”的名字出售它。嗯，那不是一个吸引人的标题，所以我明白为什么他们必须润色一下。很快，他开始大规模生产并运往其他地方。他变得如此富有，以至于能够退休。哇。在1924年。哇。所以只卖了14年的沙拉酱。他就说，再见。我们应该做一种沙拉酱吗？我们的沙拉酱是什么？里面会有什么？
What do you like in a salad dressing, lady? Well, you had me at mayonnaise. Okay. So we'll do some kind of mayo-based salad dressing. I also like lemon. Do those mix? I don't know. I don't know because I was going to say maybe like a spicy mustard. Oh. Because I know they do a honey mustard salad dressing, but has anyone paired a spicy mustard with a mayo yet?
女士，你喜欢沙拉酱里有什么？嗯，你用蛋黄酱吸引了我。好吧。所以我们会做某种以蛋黄酱为基础的沙拉酱。我也喜欢柠檬。它们能混在一起吗？我不知道。我不知道，因为我本来想说也许像辣芥末。哦。因为我知道他们有蜂蜜芥末沙拉酱，但有人把辣芥末和蛋黄酱配对过吗？
Probably. We need to cut this out. We need to cut this out because we're on to something and we'll never do it and someone else will and then we'll be mad for the rest of our lives. Office ladies. But we need to give it a really long clunky name. Office ladies. Creamy mayonnaise. Spicy mustard delight.
可能吧。我们需要剪掉这个。我们需要剪掉这个，因为我们发现了什么，而我们永远不会去做，别人会去做，然后我们会后悔一辈子。办公室女士。但我们需要给它起一个非常长且笨拙的名字。办公室女士。奶油蛋黄酱。辣芥末之乐。
Yes. And then later... Delight's got to go on the end. I don't care what it is. Later, we'll call it like Dutch dressing. We'll just pick a country. Denmark dressing. We'll just pick a random country.
是的。然后稍后……“之乐”必须放在最后。我不在乎它是什么。稍后，我们会叫它像荷兰调料。我们随便选一个国家。丹麦调料。我们随便选一个国家。
Pick a country. Okay. This is the formula. Okay. And then we'll retire in 14 years. Okay. All right. My final fun fact about Nashua is also about Amy Ryan.
选一个国家。好吧。这就是配方。好吧。然后我们14年后退休。好吧。好了。我关于纳舒厄的最后一个趣事也是关于艾米·瑞安的。
Her character in Gone Baby Gone. Yeah. She is being interrogated. Yeah. about a possible drug deal. Yeah. And she admits that she did, in fact, make a drug run to Nashua. No.
她在《失踪的宝贝》中的角色。是啊。她正在接受审讯。是啊。关于可能的毒品交易。是啊。她承认她确实去纳舒厄跑了一趟毒品。不。
And she made $150,000 on this drug run. Amy, what is it? All your roles lead back to Nashua. I don't know. Love it. I now need to Google Nashua. Why? I already told you everything you need to know.
她在这次毒品交易中赚了15万美元。艾米，这是怎么回事？你所有的角色都回到了纳舒厄。我不知道。喜欢它。我现在需要谷歌一下纳舒厄。为什么？我已经告诉你所有你需要知道的了。
There's only three things to know about Nashua and I've told you what they are. Well, I need to Google Image, Nashua. It's really cute. I'm a big fan of the Google Image button, guys. the button. Like I say it like it's an actual button on my computer. I would love it if it was a button on my computer. Less clicking. Yeah. Okay. Before we get into... That's our next addiction. Yeah. Like computers for old people. Before we get into employee transfer, I want to share that there is another great DVD commentary for this episode from our crew. And I want to let them introduce
关于纳舒厄只有三件事要知道，我已经告诉你了。嗯，我需要谷歌图片，纳舒厄。它真的很可爱。我是谷歌图片按钮的忠实粉丝，伙计们。按钮。就像我把它说得好像是我电脑上的一个实际按钮一样。如果它是我电脑上的一个按钮，我会很喜欢。点击更少。是啊。好吧。在我们进入……那是我们的下一个瘾。是啊。就像老年人的电脑。在我们进入《员工调动》之前，我想分享一下这一集还有另一个很棒的DVD评论，来自我们的剧组。我想让他们介绍
themselves because I'm going to be bringing up some of the trivia they share. Here is the DVD crew commentary for this episode. Am I going to cry again? By the way, I'm Dave Rogers. I'm an Emmy Award-winning editor on the show, and this was my directorial debut. And to my left here is... I'm Kyle Alexander, location manager for the show. I'm Anthony Farrell, writer of this fantastic episode. I'm Veda Samar, a script supervisor. Been on the show for 99 episodes now. And I'm Philip Shea, the Property Master, and I have also been on the show since first season. I'm Chuck Kanzanari, and this was my first full year as a production assistant on the funniest show on TV.
他们自己，因为我会提到他们分享的一些花絮。这是这一集的DVD剧组评论。我又要哭了吗？顺便说一下，我是戴夫·罗杰斯。我是该剧获得艾美奖的剪辑师，这是我的导演处女作。在我左边的是……我是凯尔·亚历山大，该剧的取景经理。我是安东尼·法雷尔，这一精彩剧集的编剧。我是维达·萨马尔，剧本主管。已经在该剧工作了99集了。我是菲利普·谢伊，道具主管，我也从第一季开始就在该剧工作了。我是查克·坎扎纳里，这是我作为该剧制作助理的第一个完整年份，这是电视上最有趣的节目。
Oh my gosh. I love it. I know. I love hearing their voices. So whenever there's a crew commentary, I just want to let them introduce themselves because it just brings back so many feelings just hearing their voices. When Dave introduced himself as an Emmy-winning editor, it reminded me, Angela, that we were at that awards show.
天哪。我喜欢它。我知道。我喜欢听他们的声音。所以每当有剧组评论时，我只想让他们介绍自己，因为听到他们的声音会带回太多的感受。当戴夫介绍自己是艾美奖获奖剪辑师时，它提醒我，安吉拉，我们在那个颁奖典礼上。
Remember, we read off the people? We co-presented. Yes. And then we got to do that. give the Emmy to our own editors, and then we partied all night with them. That was so much fun. That was one of the most fun award shows. Absolutely. Yeah. Without a doubt. Yeah. So that is who does the DVD commentary for this episode. I'll sprinkle in tidbits they share. And then also, you guys, the bloopers for this episode are some of my most favorite of all bloopers.
记得吗，我们读了那些人的名字？我们共同颁奖。是的。然后我们有机会做那个。把艾美奖颁给我们自己的剪辑师，然后我们和他们整晚聚会。那太有趣了。那是颁奖典礼中最有趣的一次。绝对。是啊。毫无疑问。是啊。所以这就是为这一集做DVD评论的人。我会穿插他们分享的花絮。还有，伙计们，这一集的NG镜头是我最喜欢的NG镜头之一。
And you can't find them online. You know, they're not all there. So the bonus for this episode on the DVD box set is so great. I wish all of the driving scenes have been left in because they are all gold. I am bummed because I have every DVD set for every season except this one. What? I don't know where my season five DVD went. Oh, lady. I know. Well, while we take a break, maybe I'll order that DVD, Ang.
而且你在网上找不到它们。你知道，它们并不都在那里。所以DVD套装中这一集的奖励太棒了。我希望所有的驾驶场景都被保留下来，因为它们都是金子。我很沮丧，因为除了这一季，我每一季的DVD套装都有。什么？我不知道我的第五季DVD去哪了。哦，女士。我知道。好吧，在我们休息的时候，也许我会订购那个DVD，安。
Yeah. So I can watch these bloopers. These bloopers are my favorite, some of my absolute favorite. All right, I'll do it. We'll be right back. All right, we are back. And you guys, it is Holloway. at Dunder Mifflin.
是啊。这样我就可以看这些NG镜头了。这些NG镜头是我最喜欢的，我绝对最喜欢的一些。好了，我会做的。我们马上回来。好了，我们回来了。伙计们，是万圣节。在邓德·米夫林。
It sure is. This is our Halloween cold open. Not through the rest of the episode, just in the cold open. Well, we found out why. Let's play Anthony's first clip. He talks all about it. The show was initially, the entire episode was supposed to be Halloween. So everyone was in their costumes for the entire episode.
确实是。这是我们的万圣节冷开场。不是在这一集的其余部分，只是在冷开场。好吧，我们发现了原因。让我们播放安东尼的第一个片段。他谈到了这一切。该剧最初，整集应该是万圣节。所以每个人在整集中都穿着他们的服装。
So Andy was a kitten initially. I think, and the whole beast story with Dwight being in the Cornell sweater, that was his costume, an accidental costume initially. And that's where that story came from. So costume-wise, we had a thing where once we decided we were going to just put the Halloween stuff in the cold open, we rewrote the cold open. And that was mostly led by Lee and Gene. And that's where the idea for the three Jokers came from. That was obviously a situation that year with that costume being super popular.
所以安迪最初是一只小猫。我想，德怀特穿着康奈尔毛衣的整个故事，那是他的服装，最初是一个意外的服装。这就是那个故事的来源。所以服装方面，我们有一个决定，一旦我们决定只把万圣节的东西放在冷开场，我们就重写了冷开场。这主要是由李和吉恩领导的。这就是三个小丑的想法来源。那显然是那一年那个服装超级受欢迎的情况。
And they just totally made the most of that situation. It was amazing. The Charlie Chapman thing, that was actually a full, like, runner for you, Jenna. And we had initially in the first draft where you were going to be, it was Halloween all day. So it was just going to be you running around the New York office as the only person dressed for Halloween, trying not to look like Hitler. And it was a fun little runner for you. But I think the story we got eventually with Jim's brothers and that beautiful thing with, you know,
他们完全利用了那种情况。太棒了。查理·卓别林的事，那实际上是一个完整的，像，为你准备的跑动，珍娜。我们最初在第一稿中，你是，那是整天的万圣节。所以你只是在纽约办公室里跑来跑去，作为唯一一个穿着万圣节服装的人，试图看起来不像希特勒。这对你来说是一个有趣的小跑动。但我认为我们最终得到的关于吉姆兄弟的故事，以及那个美丽的，你知道，
you taking the heat like that around them and having that nice little moment. I think that, that to me felt more right. And I love that we ended up going there with the story. Yeah. It was going to be a whole Halloween episode and then they changed it up. Yes, Anthony shared in the DVD that all those Halloween costumes would actually be distracting from all the other storylines. Uh-huh. So they just made it the cold open.
你那样承受压力，并有那个美好的小时刻。我认为，对我来说，那感觉更对。我喜欢我们最终用那个故事走到那里。是啊。那本来是一整集的万圣节，然后他们改变了。是的，安东尼在DVD中分享说，所有那些万圣节服装实际上会分散对所有其他故事情节的注意力。嗯哼。所以他们只是把它变成了冷开场。
And I have a costume breakdown. Oh, good, because I have some good details about some of the costumes. Okay. What's everyone wearing, Angela? So we have the scripts thanks to Jamesopedia. Mm-hmm. So per the script, here are some details. Stanley, in the script, it says, is wearing a creature from the Black Lagoon rubber mask with his regular suit.
我有一个服装解析。哦，太好了，因为我有一些关于服装的好细节。好吧。每个人都穿什么，安吉拉？所以我们有剧本，多亏了詹姆斯百科。嗯哼。所以根据剧本，这里有一些细节。斯坦利，在剧本里说，戴着一个来自黑湖妖的橡胶面具，穿着他的正装。
Okay. Creed, per the script, is an amazing joker from Batman, whereas Kevin is a, quote, lame joker. And in the script, it says Dwight is also a joker. Kelly is Carrie Bradshaw from Sex and the City. Ryan is Gordon Gecko from Wall Street. Very fitting for Ryan. Oscar is Uncle Sam. Meredith, a cheerleader.
好吧。克里德，根据剧本，是一个来自蝙蝠侠的惊人小丑，而凯文是一个，引用，蹩脚的小丑。在剧本里，它说德怀特也是一个小丑。凯利是《欲望都市》里的凯莉·布拉德肖。瑞安是《华尔街》里的戈登·盖柯。非常适合瑞安。奥斯卡是山姆大叔。梅雷迪思，一个啦啦队长。
Phyllis is Raggedy Ann. Andy, per the script, it says he's dressed as a cat with whiskers. on his face. Angela has brought back her cat costume. Yes. Always a classic. And Jim is just wearing a name tag that says Dave. And of course, Pam, the solo Halloween costume wear at corporate is dressed as Charlie Chaplin.
菲利斯是拉格迪·安。安迪，根据剧本，它说他打扮成一只猫，脸上带着胡须。安吉拉带回了她的猫服装。是的。永远是经典。吉姆只是戴着一个写着“戴夫”的名牌。当然，帕姆，公司里唯一的万圣节服装穿着者，打扮成查理·卓别林。
Yes. I reached out to our wardrobe designer, Alicia Raycraft. Oh, great. So starting this season, Alicia took over for Carrie Bennett. Uh-huh. Alicia was amazing, particularly, I think, at building wardrobe from scratch. My memories of her when I would visit her in the wardrobe trailer were that she always had like one of those fabric mannequins with like swatches on it pinned on it or on her wall. I am telling
是的。我联系了我们的服装设计师，艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫特。哦，太好了。所以从这一季开始，艾丽西亚接替了嘉莉·贝内特。嗯哼。艾丽西亚很棒，特别是在从零开始制作服装方面。我访问她在服装拖车里时对她的记忆是，她总是有一个那种织物人体模型，上面别着布料样本，或者在她的墙上。我告诉你
you she was always pinning something to something. Yes. And then standing back and looking at it and then moving a swatch here up and down. She said that with this episode, she had to really ride the line of designing wardrobe, but also making sure that the costumes look like things that we could put together ourselves. Right. The idea is that if Kevin is going to dress like the Joker, it'd be Kevin's effort. I'd be like something Kevin had to put together. Yes. Like you said, the script said that Creed's Joker was supposed to be the best version of the Joker. Kevin's was supposed to be lame. And they're the Dark Knight Joker. Yes, that's what Alicia said. They were supposed to be based on the Heath Ledger Joker.
她总是把什么东西别在什么东西上。是的。然后退后看着它，然后把样本上下移动。她说在这一集中，她必须真正走在设计服装的界限上，但也确保服装看起来像我们可以自己拼凑的东西。对。想法是，如果凯文要打扮成小丑，那应该是凯文的努力。那应该是凯文必须拼凑的东西。是的。就像你说的，剧本说克里德的小丑应该是小丑的最佳版本。凯文的应该是蹩脚的。他们是《黑暗骑士》的小丑。是的，艾丽西亚就是这么说的。他们应该是基于希斯·莱杰的小丑。
And so she had a picture and she made a shopping list and she still had her shopping list. Stop it. I love her. This is what it said. They had to go shop for a vest with a high neck center front. Green for Creed, not for Kevin. Because Creed got it right and Kevin didn't. Correct.
所以她有一张照片，她做了一份购物清单，她仍然有她的购物清单。别这样。我喜欢她。这就是它说的。他们必须去买一件高领中心前部的背心。克里德是绿色的，凯文不是。因为克里德做对了，而凯文没有。正确。
They needed a gray or dark lilac patterned shirt. Green or olive tie with a pattern. Pinstripe Navy pants pleaded for Kevin but flat front for Creed. Argyle socks. black Oxford shoes for Creed, but Kevin is to wear his regular character shoes. She said the overall direction in shopping for Kevin was that all of the clothes they purchased should look like they came from his closet. And the direction for Creed was that Creed went out and picked it out specifically for Halloween. Yeah.
他们需要一件灰色或深紫色的图案衬衫。绿色或橄榄色的领带，带有图案。细条纹海军蓝裤子，凯文是褶皱的，但克里德是平面的。菱形袜。克里德穿黑色牛津鞋，但凯文要穿他平时的角色鞋。她说为凯文购物的总体方向是，他们购买的所有衣服都应该看起来像是从他的衣柜里出来的。而克里德的方向是，克里德专门为万圣节挑选了它。是啊。
But for Dwight, she said they went with a nod to the Jack Nicholson version of The Joker. I thought something was different when I rewatched it because the way they drew the smile, Yes. Did not look like the Heath Ledger Joker. That's how they were like, how do we do three jokers, but it's not all the same costume or the same look. But she also shared with me that she brought in a rack of clothes and that Rain really put together his costume from everything she had bought, which tracks with when we talked to Carrie. And Carrie Bennett said that Rain was always really invested in what his character wore. That's awesome. So let's see. What's next? We got a lot of questions about Andy's kitten costume. A lot of people wrote in to say they thought it looked a little
但对于德怀特，她说他们向杰克·尼科尔森版本的小丑致敬。我重看时觉得有什么不同，因为他们画笑容的方式，是的。看起来不像希斯·莱杰的小丑。这就是他们如何像，我们如何做三个小丑，但不是所有的服装或外观都一样。但她也和我分享说，她带进了一排衣服，雷恩确实从她买的所有东西中拼凑了他的服装，这与我们和嘉莉交谈时一致。嘉莉·贝内特说雷恩总是非常投入于他的角色穿什么。太棒了。那么，看看。接下来是什么？我们收到了很多关于安迪小猫服装的问题。很多人写信说他们觉得它看起来有点
bit like, my favorite was Katie L. said it looks like an off-brand rum-tum-tugger costume from the musical Cats. She said, in my mind, I like to think Andy was in a school production of Cats and he still had his costume. Katie L, you would be right on there. Dave told me that Greg was very involved in Ed's costume. Really? Yes, that he wanted it to look like it was from the musical Cats, and he went over the top to please Angela. Right.
像，我最喜欢的是凯蒂·L说的，它看起来像音乐剧《猫》中非品牌的“朗·汤姆·塔格”服装。她说，在我脑海里，我喜欢认为安迪在学校制作的《猫》中，他仍然有他的服装。凯蒂·L，你说对了。戴夫告诉我，格雷格非常参与埃德的服装。真的吗？是的，他希望它看起来像是来自音乐剧《猫》，他为了取悦安吉拉而做得过火了。对。
He was not just going to draw whiskers on his face, guys. Alicia said she showed Greg a bunch of photos from the Broadway musical of Cats, and Greg picked his favorites, but she did not base this cat on any one character. It was a meld. She built that whole costume from scratch. She bought a Unitarred and hand-painted it. She used to do textile painting. Wow.
伙计们，他不仅仅是在脸上画胡须。艾丽西亚说她给格雷格看了很多百老汇音乐剧《猫》的照片，格雷格选了他最喜欢的，但她并没有把这只猫基于任何一个角色。这是一个融合。她从零开始制作了整套服装。她买了一件连体衣并手工绘制。她过去常做纺织绘画。哇。
That's amazing. And then she found another email that she shared with me. It was an email to her crew detailing how to build the little, like, fur diaper thing that he's wearing. What is it? Right. Yeah, I don't know. It looks like fur underwear. And then there's also like a rope belt and a tail.
太神奇了。然后她发现了另一封她和我分享的邮件。这是一封发给她剧组的邮件，详细说明了如何制作他穿的那种小的，像，毛皮尿布的东西。那是什么？对。是啊，我不知道。看起来像毛皮内衣。然后还有像绳带和尾巴。
And oh, my goodness. Yes. She said, please make a loin cloth using a fong or small brief underwear. as a base and then swatch Phelps, wool crepe, and heavy knits on top, and please get faux fur for some gloves. So amazing. So that is how she put together all of those costumes, which were really amazing. And I remember my costume. We did like, Pam went to a store and rented a tucks, basically. Well, I took a lot of photos this day. I have some great ones of you and rain. You guys were hanging out by your trailer. I was walking by you guys.
哦，天哪。是的。她说，请用丁字裤或小内裤作为基础制作一块缠腰布，然后在上面贴上菲尔普斯、羊毛绉纱和厚针织物，请为一些手套准备人造毛皮。太神奇了。所以这就是她如何拼凑所有那些服装，它们真的很棒。我记得我的服装。我们做了像，帕姆去了一家商店租了一件燕尾服，基本上。嗯，我那天拍了很多照片。我有几张你和雷恩的很棒的照片。你们在你们的拖车旁闲逛。我走过你们身边，
in my cat costume, and I see Rain as the Joker talking to Jenna as Charlie Chaplin, just casually hanging out. And so I took pictures. They're some of my favorite. Well, I think he put that one in his book. I gave it to him. Yeah. That's for me. I loved this episode, Angela, because I had been away for a very long time at Pratt, but you know, the corporate offices were over on the warehouse set. We never got to see you. But you did on this day. Exactly. And I got to participate in the holidays. Halloween, which was always one of my favorite things on our show. And I would have been really bummed if I didn't get to see everybody in their costumes. But I got to be in hair makeup. And we were in there a long time. Me, not so long. But oh my gosh, Ed had to come in really early. Yeah. And so did Phyllis.
穿着我的猫服装，我看到雷恩作为小丑和打扮成查理·卓别林的珍娜在随意地闲逛。所以我拍了照片。它们是我最喜欢的照片之一。嗯，我想他把那张放进他的书里了。我给了他。是啊。那是给我的。我喜欢这一集，安吉拉，因为我在普拉特待了很长时间，但你知道，公司办公室在仓库布景那边。我们从来没见过你。但你那天见了。完全正确。我得以参加节日。万圣节，这一直是我在我们的节目中最喜欢的事情之一。如果我没能看到每个人穿上他们的服装，我会很沮丧。但我得以在发型和化妆间。我们在那里待了很长时间。我，没那么久。但哦，天哪，埃德必须很早就进来。是啊。菲利斯也是。
Like, there was a lot of makeup there. Well, my hair was not easy to wash out. I'll tell you that. Are your eyebrows? I felt bad for your poor eyebrows. Yeah. It was a real grease paint. They shellacked you. Yeah. I have a few little background catches. for this cold open. I want you guys to know that at 44 seconds, when Kevin is annoyed that Creed is such a good joker, he brushes past me and knocks me over. This was like a little running bit Brian and I would have that if Kevin bumped into Angela, she'd go flying. It was like our own personal bit that cracked us up to no end. When he did it, one of my cat ears fell forward and didn't come back up. And I could feel it laying on top of my head. And I was trying not to laugh. And if you go to 44
就像，那里有很多化妆。嗯，我的头发不容易洗掉。我告诉你。你的眉毛呢？我为你的可怜眉毛感到难过。是啊。那是真正的油彩。他们把你涂满了。是啊。我有一些小的背景捕捉。为了这个冷开场。我想让你们知道，在44秒时，当凯文因为克里德是一个如此好的小丑而感到恼火时，他擦过我并把我撞倒了。这就像布莱恩和我会有的一点小跑动，如果凯文撞到安吉拉，她就会飞出去。这就像我们自己的个人片段，让我们笑得停不下来。当他做的时候，我的一只猫耳朵向前倒下，没有再弹回来。我能感觉到它躺在我的头顶上。我试图不笑。如果你去44
seconds, you'll see that Angela's ear flops forward. I want you to know that three people that I reached out to on this episode pointed out that moment to me. I know. I know they talked about it in the commentary, too. I think it's gone down in the lore of this episode. I know. And then the other thing was, you guys, they really let Ed as that cat play around and mess with John. And in one take, Ed as Andy came up to Jim and rubbed on his leg, like kind of rubbed on him like a cat. And the two of them locked. And the two of them lost. And then It's in the bloopers, but they had a lot of fun with that. One of my favorite moments is when Andy, it says in the script, Andy walks back to his desk smugly.
秒，你会看到安吉拉的耳朵向前翻。我想让你们知道，我联系的这一集的三个人向我指出了那一刻。我知道。我知道他们在评论中也谈到了它。我想它已经载入了这一集的传说。我知道。还有一件事是，伙计们，他们真的让埃德作为那只猫玩耍并戏弄约翰。在一次拍摄中，埃德作为安迪走到吉姆身边，在他的腿上蹭，就像猫一样蹭他。他们两个锁定了。他们两个输了。然后它在NG镜头里，但他们玩得很开心。我最喜欢的时刻之一是当安迪，剧本里说，安迪得意地走回他的办公桌。
And Ed's like sashay in that cat costume cracked me up. You guys know we love this fake elevator in our lobby, the Dundermifflin lobby. Yeah. We've talked about it. Two wooden doors and a guy pulling a rope. Yep. On the side. And they add all the sound effects later.
埃德在猫服装里那种摇摆让我笑死了。你们知道我们喜欢我们大厅里的这个假电梯，邓德·米夫林大厅。是啊。我们谈过它。两扇木门和一个拉绳子的人。是的。在侧面。他们稍后添加了所有的音效。
They add it all in. Well, in the script, when Rain as Dwight arrives in the Joker outfit, he just was supposed to hop in the elevator and he was supposed to, all of the Joker say, and here we go! And the doors would shut. But it was just kind of falling flat. So they came up with this alt about the magic trick of the pencil disappearing. Yeah. And it wasn't really working still. And so Anthony pitched, what if the doors close as he's saying the line? And then he opens them back up to finish the sentence. And they said they play the around with this for a bit with the doors opening and closing, which you and I know means that there was someone pulling a rope. Working that pulley really hard. And that's how they found this moment. And I thought that was really fun. That is awesome. Those things that happened on the fly like that in the moment, I love to hear about. Now it's time to get into the episode. We're down in the warehouse. They are loading up a big truck so that they can take Holly to Nashua. Yes. We got a fan question. Okay.
他们把一切都加进去了。嗯，在剧本里，当雷恩作为德怀特穿着小丑装到达时，他只是应该跳进电梯，他应该，所有的小丑说，我们走吧！门会关上。但这有点平淡。所以他们想出了这个关于铅笔消失的魔术的替代方案。是啊。它仍然没有真正起作用。所以安东尼推销，如果门在他说话时关上会怎样？然后他把它们重新打开来完成句子。他们说他们用门开关玩了一会儿，你们和我知道这意味着有人在拉绳子。非常努力地操作那个滑轮。这就是他们发现这一刻的方式。我觉得这真的很有趣。太棒了。那些在瞬间发生的即兴事情，我喜欢听。现在是时候进入这一集了。我们在仓库里。他们正在装载一辆大卡车，这样他们就可以带霍莉去纳舒厄。是的。我们有一个粉丝问题。好吧。
That is very funny to me. Two people. Okay. Ian O. and Mary S. wrote in to say, did Holly live in the warehouse? Isn't it odd that this road trip started from the office rather than from her home? This is such a good catch. It's true. Where is this stuff coming from? Oh my gosh. I guess we have to justify it that they went to her apartment, packed it up, but then why did they drive? to the warehouse. Why not just leave? This piggybacks very nicely on a question that I had, along with Aaron S and Amanda E, what is Holly wearing on the day she is moving? She is dressed in her work clothes, same as Pam, driving to Pratt. I know. What is that? Michael's more casual. He's got his little casual little, like, zipping jacket. Yes. Also, they pointed out, I don't think it looks like she had any intention of helping move any of her own belongings. She is not dressed for a move. No, she's not.
这对我来说很有趣。两个人。好吧。伊恩·O和玛丽·S写信说，霍莉住在仓库里吗？这次公路旅行从办公室而不是从她家开始，这不奇怪吗？这是一个很好的捕捉。是真的。这些东西是从哪里来的？哦，天哪。我想我们必须证明他们去了她的公寓，打包了它，但为什么他们开车？去仓库。为什么不直接离开？这很好地支持了我有一个问题，和亚伦·S和阿曼达·E一起，霍莉在搬家那天穿什么？她穿着她的工作服，和帕姆一样，开车去普拉特。我知道。那是什么？迈克尔更随意。他穿着他的小休闲拉链夹克。是的。还有，他们指出，我不认为看起来她有任何打算帮助搬运她自己的任何财物。她没有为搬家穿衣服。不，她没有。
Why could she be casual? What's happening? I thought these were good catches. You know, I talked to Dave about this, and he said that during the prep for this episode, they brought him a bunch of trucks to look at, and they were all giant 18-wheeler moving trucks. And he was like, how am I going to film with that? How do I tow it? What am I doing?
她为什么能这么随意？发生了什么？我认为这些是很好的捕捉。你知道，我和戴夫谈过这个，他说在这一集的准备过程中，他们带了一堆卡车给他看，它们都是巨大的18轮搬家卡车。他说我怎么用那个拍摄？我怎么拖它？我在做什么？
But he said he loves this truck that they found. It looked really realistic. He also just loved that the back was open because then when you got shots that, you know, the farther shots of them going down the road, it's just like, you really felt the move. Because you could see her bed. You could see the stuff. Right. They said that they wanted the table hanging off the front, like in the bubble wrap. I love it. I loved it too. Phil props. You know, we love Phil props. He shared that Anthony and Dave really wanted my. to have packed all kinds of crazy things for the road trip. Like him and Holly are little kids, like the finger puppets and the cats in the cradle and the movies to watch. You guys, a lot of those are in the deleted scenes. Of them doing it in the van? And my absolute favorite is the two of them.
但他表示他很喜欢他们找到的这辆卡车。看起来非常逼真。他也特别喜欢车厢是敞开的设计，因为这样当你拍摄他们行驶在路上的远景镜头时，你真的能感受到那种移动感。因为你能看到车斗，能看到里面的东西。没错。他们说想要那张桌子挂在车头外面，就像用泡泡纸包着那样。我喜欢这个点子。我也很喜欢。菲尔的道具。你知道的，我们很爱菲尔的道具。他分享说安东尼和戴夫真的很想让我为这次公路旅行打包各种疯狂的东西。就像他和霍莉是小孩子一样，比如手指木偶、翻绳游戏，还有要看的电影。你们知道吗，其中很多都在删减片段里。他们是在货车里做的？而我绝对最喜欢的是他们两个。
The windows are down and they're watching a movie and they are pissing themselves laughing. They are laughing so hard. And Darrell looks miserable. And Darrell takes a hard turn on purpose. and the laptop that's playing the movie goes flying out the window. I remember that. It is so funny. I am so bummed it didn't make it in.
车窗摇下来，他们正在看电影，笑得前仰后合。他们笑得太厉害了。而达里尔看起来很痛苦。达里尔故意猛地转弯，正在播放电影的笔记本电脑就飞出了窗外。我记得那个。太搞笑了。没能放进正片里我真的很遗憾。
Dave said they spent three hours on that gag and finally had to just let it go. They said every time Craig turned, the computer would slide and never go out the window. It only went out the window one time. Oh, my gosh. But it's in the bloopers on the DVD, and it's so funny. We had a fan catch from a couple of people, from a couple of people. Erica S and Mary S. And I have to say they're making a good point. What? So it's said repeatedly in Goodbye Toby that, you know, she's coming in to train for this new
戴夫说他们在那场戏上花了三个小时，最后不得不放弃。他们说每次克雷格转弯时，电脑就会滑开，但就是飞不出窗外。它只飞出窗外过一次。天哪。但这在DVD的NG花絮里，真的太搞笑了。我们收到了几位粉丝的反馈，来自埃里卡·S和玛丽·S。我必须说她们指出了一个很好的点。什么？在《再见托比》里反复提到，你知道的，她要来接受这个新
position and that they only allowed one day for training. And when she's on the Ferris wheel with Michael, she talks about how she was unable to be promoted at her former company. Former company. Right, right. But then in this episode, it says she's being transferred. back to Nashua as if she's been a Dundermifflin employee all along. I don't know, guys. I mean, I think they caught a continuity error there. Oh, yeah. Here's one of the things I was curious about.
职位的培训，而且他们只给了一天的培训时间。当她和迈克尔在摩天轮上时，她谈到她在前一家公司无法获得晋升。前一家公司。对，没错。但在这集里，却说她被调回了纳舒厄，就好像她一直都是邓德·米夫林公司的员工一样。我不知道，伙计们。我的意思是，我觉得他们抓到了一个连续性错误。哦，是的。这是我好奇的事情之一。
Why would Daryl agree to drive Michael and Holly be in a car with Michael and Holly for seven hours? Well, there was a talking head in the script that didn't make it in. That explained this. Daryl said, I'm driving them up for five times what I would have. made it work. I thought I made a good deal. Then I realized I'm going to be trapped in a truck with Michael all day. But he did earn a lot of money. So Michael paid him is why. They paid him, yeah. Okay. That does make more sense. Well, Michael is not the only person who's leaving for the day. Jim comes walking out of the building. He's saying goodbye to them, right? And we find out that Jim is going to go to New York and he's
为什么达里尔会同意开车送迈克尔和霍莉，还要和他们待在车里七个小时？嗯，剧本里有一个没被采用的采访镜头解释了这一点。达里尔说，我送他们过去赚的钱是平时的五倍，这很划算。我以为我做了一笔好交易。然后我意识到我得整天被困在卡车里和迈克尔待在一起。但他确实赚了很多钱。所以迈克尔付钱给他就是原因。他们付钱给他，是的。好吧。那确实说得通。嗯，迈克尔并不是今天唯一要离开的人。吉姆从大楼里走出来。他在和他们道别，对吧？我们发现吉姆要去纽约，他
going to have lunch with Pam and his two brothers. So we set up that storyline. And I'm bringing this up because at 3 minutes 24 seconds, Jim is holding the keychain that he got in the Yankee swap Christmas party from Oscar back in season two. Oh my gosh. What a great tiny detail. Yeah. I love that. Phil Shea. Phil Shea. Man. Well, as Jim and Michael are having this little scene in the parking lot, Holly would have said goodbye to everyone in the bullpen. It was a deleted scene. Jenna, I laughed so hard in this scene. I was. really glad I'm way deep behind the partition. It's a series of people saying goodbye to her, but my absolute favorite was Oscar. Oscar Nunez is so good at like being the character that reigns
要和帕姆还有他的两个兄弟吃午饭。所以我们铺垫了那条故事线。我提到这个是因为在3分24秒时，吉姆拿着他在第二季洋基交换礼物圣诞派对上从奥斯卡那里得到的钥匙扣。天哪。多么棒的小细节。是的。我喜欢那个。菲尔·谢。菲尔·谢。天哪。好吧，当吉姆和迈克尔在停车场有这一小段戏时，霍莉本该和办公室里的每个人道别。那是一个删减片段。珍娜，我在这一幕笑得好大声。我当时真的很高兴我躲在隔板后面很深的地方。这是一系列人跟她道别的场景，但我绝对最喜欢的是奥斯卡。奥斯卡·努涅斯非常擅长扮演那种给你
on your parade, but he's just being reasonable, right? Yes. So he's like, you know, well, good luck. And she's like, well, I won't be that far. And then he goes on to say all of this. And he just slowly, slowly reigns on her parade. Can you play it? We'll miss you. Oh, well, I'll be around. It's an seven-hour drive. Well, it's not that bad. But if I'm really jonesing to see you guys, I can always fly. I don't know if it'll be shorter to fly.
泼冷水，但又表现得合情合理的角色，对吧？是的。所以他说，嗯，祝你好运。她说，嗯，我不会离得太远。然后他接着说了所有这些话。他只是慢慢地、慢慢地给她泼冷水。你能放一下吗？我们会想你的。哦，嗯，我会常回来的。开车要七个小时。嗯，没那么糟。但如果我真的很想见你们，我随时可以坐飞机。我不知道坐飞机是不是会更快。
You have to drive to Boston, right? That's an hour and a half. Get to an hour before the flight. Now you're up two and a half hours. The flight to Philadelphia is an hour of 15. It's another two and a half hour drive to Scranton. Assuming there's no traffic. Well, I just want to say goodbye. Okay. Okay.
你得先开车去波士顿，对吧？那要一个半小时。起飞前一小时到达机场。现在你已经花了两个半小时了。飞往费城的航班要一小时十五分钟。再开车两个半小时到斯克兰顿。假设没有交通堵塞的话。好吧，我只是想说再见。好吧。好吧。
It made me laugh so hard. I just wanted to say goodbye. Right, right. But like she's trying to make, like, it's not going to be that bad. And he's like, well, I don't know about that. Like that person, Oscar was so good at being that person. So it keeps coming up in this episode that it is seven hours from Scranton to Nashua. Did you Google it?
这让我笑得好大声。我只是想说再见。对，对。但她试图表现得好像，这不会那么糟糕。而他说，嗯，我可不这么认为。就像那个人，奥斯卡非常擅长扮演那种人。所以这一集里一直提到从斯克兰顿到纳舒厄要七个小时。你谷歌过了吗？
It's not true. How far is it? Less than five. What? It's such a big difference. Why didn't anyone look that up at the right? No, but it's only like four hours and 45 minutes. Are you kidding me?
这不是真的。有多远？不到五小时。什么？差别这么大。为什么当时没人查一下？不，其实只有四个小时四十五分钟。你在开玩笑吗？
I'm not kidding you. What roads were they taking? Are there new freeways? There were some like fan theories that it took them seven hours in that big truck. But that's not how we present it in this episode. We present it like how are they ever going to see each other? Like Holly says even if you leave right after work, Michael, you won't even get her until after midnight. And then we'll just have one day together.
我没开玩笑。他们走的是什么路？有新的高速公路吗？有一些粉丝理论说他们在那辆大卡车里花了七个小时。但我们在这一集中并不是这样呈现的。我们呈现的方式是他们怎么可能再见到对方？就像霍莉说的，即使你下班后马上出发，迈克尔，你也要到午夜之后才能见到她。然后我们在一起的时间就只有一天了。
And you'll have to go back, but it's not true. They really scared themselves. I mean, at four hours, they're in the middle of nowhere. That's how we sell it. Exactly. Oh, wow. I know. So anyway, I just wanted to say that.
然后你就得回去，但这并不是真的。他们真的把自己吓到了。我的意思是，在四个小时的时候，他们就在荒郊野外了。我们就是这样卖这个点的。没错。哦，哇。我知道。所以总之，我只是想说这个。
I also did check the train schedule. For a reason, I can't explain, it takes over 12 hours on the train. Maybe our writers check the train schedule. I don't know. A lot of stops, though, I guess. Oh, my gosh. Yeah, I know. Are you checking my work?
我还查了火车时刻表。出于某种我无法解释的原因，坐火车要超过12个小时。也许我们的编剧查了火车时刻表。我不知道。我想停靠站很多吧。天哪。是的，我知道。你在检查我的工作吗？
you got your phone out. She is checking my work. I'm not checking. What do you think? I don't know how to Scranton to Nashua? No, I'm very curious. After all of my great information I've given you about rainbies. Can I tell you something right now? What? I'm doing it too. We're both Googling Scranton to Nashua. There it is, five hours. It's 311 miles. Done. You know what's amazing is that a lot of people have written about this. I know. There's a whole Reddit thread. I know. I'm looking at the Reddit thread. See? Okay. Well, this shouldn't have broken them up. It really shouldn't have. They should have picked a further branch. Okay. Well, all right. Speaking of all of these driving scenes, should we get into it a little bit? We'll come back. Stuff is happening back at the office with Dwight and Andy, but we'll get back to it.
你拿出手机了。她在检查我的工作。我没在检查。你觉得呢？我不知道斯克兰顿到纳舒厄怎么走？不，我很好奇。在我给了你关于雨人这么多精彩信息之后。我现在能告诉你一件事吗？什么？我也在查。我们都在谷歌斯克兰顿到纳舒厄。找到了，五个小时。311英里。搞定。你知道最神奇的是什么吗？很多人写过这个。我知道。有一个完整的Reddit帖子。我知道。我正在看那个Reddit帖子。看吧？好吧。这本不该让他们分手的。真的不该。他们应该选一个更远的分部。好吧，好吧。说到所有这些驾驶场景，我们要不要深入聊聊？我们会回来的。办公室里德怀特和安迪那边还有事情发生，但我们会回到那里的。
Should we do the driving? Let's do it. Let's get to the driving. Sam. If you're going something all night long. Okay. Tom Cochran. According to Jamesapedia, they had two days and a little more, like two days and a half to shoot the driving scenes. They shot mostly on the 118 freeway, a little bit on Burbank Boulevard. That's how we made it look like the East Coast. Some tidbits from Dave Rogers. They filmed this using lipstick cameras in the car, and for the most part, used a tow car. So they had a big old truck that pulled the truck. Craig was not actually driving. So Dave told me that it was over 100 degrees the days they were shooting. 104 is what they said in the commentary.
我们要聊驾驶戏吗？来吧。让我们进入驾驶戏。萨姆。如果你整晚都在做某事。好吧。汤姆·科克伦。根据《詹姆斯百科》，他们有两天多一点，大概两天半的时间来拍摄驾驶场景。他们主要是在118号高速公路上拍摄的，还有一点是在伯班克大道。这就是我们让它看起来像东海岸的方法。来自戴夫·罗杰斯的一些花絮。他们用车载口红摄像机拍摄，大部分时间用的是拖车。所以他们有一辆大卡车拉着那辆卡车。克雷格实际上并没有在开车。所以戴夫告诉我，他们拍摄的那几天气温超过了100华氏度。评论音轨里说是104度。
And he, Randall Einhorn, our DP, Paul Fieg, and Veda had to sit in the back of the tow car. Under a tent. Yes, like a black box tent where they could see monitors showing them what was happening inside the car. They had little walkie-talkies so that they could talk to Amy and. and Steve and Craig, he said Paul Figue started removing layers of his suit because you know, Paul used to wear like a three-piece suit every day. Yeah. Yeah. He said they were really jealous because Randall Eynhorn wore the cooling vest. Yes. Yeah. The cooling vest that Steve Karel had worn. Yeah. Veda said inside the tent with five monitors, all the heat was trapped in there. She said it
而他、兰德尔·艾因霍恩（我们的摄影指导）、保罗·费格和维达不得不坐在拖车的后面。在一个帐篷下面。是的，就像一个黑盒子帐篷，他们可以看到显示车内情况的监视器。他们有小对讲机，这样他们就可以和艾米、史蒂夫还有克雷格说话。他说保罗·费格开始脱掉西装的层数，因为你知道，保罗以前每天都穿三件套西装。是的。是的。他说他们真的很嫉妒，因为兰德尔·艾因霍恩穿了冷却背心。是的。是的，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔穿过的那种冷却背心。是的。维达说在那个有五个监视器的帐篷里，所有的热量都被困在里面了。她说
felt like it was 200 degrees in there. Dave sent me some pictures. Oh, no, were they like all melting? They were. They looked so hot. It was crazy. Yeah, so they are driving. They are singing the song over and over again. Over and over. And then, of course, in the deleted scenes, you guys, they're pulling things out of that bag michael packed and doing things. And then one of the things they do is they just start doing like kissing pushups. Oh my gosh, Daryl's face. They put their lips to each other and they're going one and two and three, and four and four like that. It's so good. And that didn't make it in, but they're driving Daryl crazy. But then they start to realize this is far. It's starting to hit them. Michael wants to save the day. He's like, stop right now. We're halfway.
感觉里面有200度。戴夫给我发了一些照片。哦，不，他们都融化了吗？是的。他们看起来太热了。太疯狂了。是的，所以他们在开车。他们一遍又一遍地唱着那首歌。一遍又一遍。然后，当然，在删减片段里，伙计们，他们从迈克尔打包的那个包里拿出东西来做各种事。其中一件他们做的事是开始做亲吻俯卧撑。天哪，达里尔的表情。他们把嘴唇贴在一起，然后做着一、二、三、四、四这样。太棒了。那段没放进正片，但他们快把达里尔逼疯了。但后来他们开始意识到这路程很远。他们开始有感觉了。迈克尔想挽救局面。他说，现在停下。我们到一半了。
There's got to be an amazing bed and breakfast right here. Yeah, it's where we'll meet. It's going to be so cute. We'll meet in the middle. So they pull off the road. There's nothing. They're in the woods. Kyle, our location manager, shared this. He said when they went tech scouting, they found this location, kind of like off the side of the road. They were like, oh, this will be perfect. But then they found out another production was filming just a little ways down the way in the same area. Who was it? He didn't say who it was. But he said, normally this wouldn't concern us because we would film in our little nook, they would film in their nook, and we'd be fine. He said, but then we found out they were filming a live band all day. And he said, we couldn't have a live band. So we had to
这儿肯定有一家很棒的民宿。是的，那是我们见面的地方。那会很可爱的。我们在中间见面。所以他们把车开下路。什么都没有。他们在树林里。凯尔，我们的外景经理，分享了这个。他说当他们去勘景时，他们发现了这个地方，就在路边。他们当时想，哦，这太完美了。但后来他们发现另一个剧组就在同一区域不远处拍摄。是谁？他没说那是谁。但他表示，通常这不会困扰我们，因为我们会在我们的小角落拍摄，他们会在他们的角落拍摄，我们会相安无事。他说，但后来我们发现他们整天都在拍一个现场乐队。他说，我们不能有现场乐队。所以我们不得不
find a whole new location. And this spot was actually in Griffith. Park. Oh, wow. Yeah. It's so funny when you said another show was filming there, I assumed it was like a murder show or 24 or something. Right. Because who else needs just like to be out in the weird woods? Maybe a teen rom-com. I guess so with a live band. Right. Here's another little thing I caught, Jenna. At nine minutes, 53 seconds, while Michael and Holly are having this heart-to-heart in the car, Daryl's getting gas. Right? Yeah. Did you see what the first front license plate said? No. It just says Rock 107. The license plate on the truck? Yes, on the front of the truck says Rock 107. Oh, my.
找一个全新的地点。而这个地方实际上是在格里菲斯公园。哦，哇。是的。当你提到另一个剧组在那里拍摄时，我以为是那种谋杀剧或者《24小时》之类的。对。因为还有谁需要待在奇怪的树林里？也许是青少年浪漫喜剧。我想是的，还有现场乐队。对。这是我注意到的另一件小事，珍娜。在9分53秒，当迈克尔和霍莉在车里谈心时，达里尔在加油。对吧？是的。你看到前车牌写着什么了吗？没有。上面写着Rock 107。卡车上的车牌？是的，卡车前面写着Rock 107。哦，我的天。
A radio station. Is there a Rock 107 in Scranton? Yes. Oh, my gosh. It plays classic rock. Of course it does, Sam. 107. Yeah, baby.
一个广播电台。斯克兰顿有Rock 107吗？有的。天哪。它播放经典摇滚。当然是这样，萨姆。107。是的，宝贝。
Although, I suppose, actually, these are all coming off of Michael's mixed CD that he made for the trip. Life is the highway. Now, we all know, I made your Scranton mixed CD. Sounds of Scranton. I would have put this on there because it was just a mix of classic rock. You know who would have appreciated my CD? Michael Scott. Michael Scott. Jennifer and Michael Scott. Yes. Hanging out. So while Daryl is getting gas, you know, Michael says that he's dated four women in the last 10 years and Holly surpasses them all. Well, Veda, our scripty, shared that the last 10 years,
虽然，我想，实际上这些都是来自迈克尔为这次旅行制作的混音CD。《公路人生》。现在，我们都知道，我为你制作了斯克兰顿混音CD。《斯克兰顿之声》。我会把这个放进去，因为它只是经典摇滚的混合。你知道谁会欣赏我的CD吗？迈克尔·斯科特。迈克尔·斯科特。詹妮弗和迈克尔·斯科特。是的。一起玩。所以当达里尔在加油时，你知道，迈克尔说他在过去10年里约会过四个女人，而霍莉超越了她们所有人。嗯，维达，我们的场记，分享说“过去10年”
was an improv from Steve. Oh, it made it so much better, I have to say. I know. I know. Everything about that when she thinks he means four people in the last year, and he says in the last 10 years, kind of at the same time. Yeah. I was like, oh, Michael. I know.
是史蒂夫的即兴发挥。哦，我必须说，这让它好多了。我知道。我知道。当她以为他指的是过去一年里的四个人，而他说是在过去10年里，那种同时发生的感觉。是的。我当时想，哦，迈克尔。我知道。
I love you so much, Michael. And they were ad-libbing right there. Aw. All of it really breaks my heart, and because as they're getting closer, you can really see Holly shutting down. Oh, she starts crying. while the song is playing. And Amy Ryan crushed that. I know. That was so good. Well, Dave talked about this. He said, you know, he really wanted a three shot. He wanted to see Michael and Holly having this
我太爱你了，迈克尔。他们当时就在那里即兴表演。啊。所有这些真的让我心碎，因为当他们越来越近时，你真的可以看到霍莉在崩溃。哦，她开始哭了。当那首歌播放的时候。艾米·瑞恩演得太棒了。我知道。那太好了。嗯，戴夫谈到了这一点。他说，你知道，他真的很想要一个三人镜头。他想看到迈克尔和霍莉有这个
moment. Michael begging Holly, no, don't do this. We don't need to break up. And Daryl just making a random phone call. Like, just he need to talk to anyone, someone. Yes. And he wanted to see all of that at the same time. I mean, it's not an easy shot, but Dave was like, no, no, no, I want to see all three of them. You had to see all three of them. Yeah. It only works that way. Because he said it's like two scenes happening at the same time. Well, maybe we should take a break from the car because we need to cover what's happening back at the office. Oh yeah. Dwight is applying for Cornell, you guys. Oh, yeah. And also, Pam's about to have lunch with Jim's brothers. There's a lot to still talk about. We'll be right back. Dwight arrives to work. Mm-hmm. He is wearing a Cornell sweatshirt.
时刻。迈克尔恳求霍莉，不，别这样。我们不需要分手。而达里尔只是在打一个随意的电话。就像，他只是需要和任何人，某个人说话。是的。他想同时看到所有这些。我的意思是，这不是一个容易的镜头，但戴夫说，不，不，不，我想看到他们三个人。你必须看到他们三个人。是的。只有那样才行。因为他说这就像两场戏同时发生。好吧，也许我们应该从车里休息一下，因为我们需要涵盖办公室里发生的事情。哦，是的。德怀特正在申请康奈尔大学，伙计们。哦，是的。还有，帕姆正要和吉姆的兄弟们吃午饭。还有很多要聊的。我们马上回来。德怀特到达办公室。嗯哼。他穿着一件康奈尔大学的运动衫。
Over his mustard shirt. Yeah. You want to know why he's wearing that sweatshirt? Because he's applying to Cornell. That's right. Yes. I mean, did he know how to go after Andy or what? Oh. What does Andy covet that Cornell diploma? My favorite thing is when you see Andy fuming in the back of Dwight's talking head. When he's bobbing his chair back and forth? So good. So good. I have a little Phil props tidbit about this talking head. Dwight is holding up a coffee mug that also says Cornell. Yeah. Well, this was sort of a last-minute pitch from Dave.
套在他的芥末色衬衫外面。是的。你想知道他为什么穿那件运动衫吗？因为他正在申请康奈尔大学。没错。是的。我的意思是，他知道怎么对付安迪吗？哦。安迪垂涎什么？那张康奈尔大学的文凭。我最喜欢的是当你看到安迪在德怀特的采访镜头背景里气得冒烟。当他在椅子上前后摇晃时？太棒了。太棒了。关于这个采访镜头，我有一个菲尔·谢的道具小花絮。德怀特举着一个也写着康奈尔的咖啡杯。是的。嗯，这是戴夫的一个临时提议。
He really wanted to pump up the Cornell merch. Okay. So he was like, what if he's holding something? They made that mug in two hours. What? Our props department. Oh, my gosh. Yeah, so that he could have it in this talking head.
他真的很想推销康奈尔的周边。好吧。所以他说，如果他手里拿着什么东西会怎样？他们两个小时内就做出了那个杯子。什么？我们的道具部门。天哪。是的，这样他就能在采访镜头里拿着它了。
You know, I've seen that happen on set sometimes where they'll be an actor and they're supposed to carry a briefcase. Yeah. For example. And the props team will. will come up during the rehearsal of the scene on the day. We're lighting, we're getting ready to shoot, and they show the actor three briefcase options. And then the actor says, oh, no, no, I imagined it would be like a distressed leather. Maybe it was my father's that they passed down to me. And the props person, you just see them just having a heart attack, basically. And I feel like the actor
你知道，我有时在片场看到这种情况，演员本该带着公文包。是的。例如。而道具组会在当天的场景排练时。我们正在布光，准备拍摄，他们给演员看三个公文包选项。然后演员说，哦，不，不，我设想它应该是那种做旧皮革的。也许是我父亲传给我的。然后道具师，你就能看到他们基本上要心脏病发作了。我觉得演员
and directors, producers, the writer of the episode, they might all have a thought last minute like that. On what this prop should look like. And the props person is like always, without fail, they're always like, oh yeah, yeah, okay. No problem. We'll get that. And then I know that they take like a van to some warehouse and they go through a giant shelf of all these briefcases to try to find the thing that the actor talked about. Or they run across the parking lot and like try to get something printed in the moment. I have such a memory of Phil running across the parking lot. My only memories of Phil are that he is running.
和导演、制片人、这一集的编剧，他们可能都会有这样的临时想法。关于这个道具应该是什么样子。而道具师总是，无一例外，他们总是说，哦，是的，是的，好的。没问题。我们会弄到的。然后我知道他们会开着货车去某个仓库，翻遍巨大的架子，试图找到演员谈论的那种东西。或者他们跑过停车场，试图当场打印出什么东西。我对菲尔跑过停车场有很深的记忆。我对菲尔唯一的记忆就是他在跑。
Running are like fast walking and talking. Hey, Phil. Hey, how's it going? No, I'm just, I got to make a coffee mug. I'm going to print out a thing and we're going to get that made. Yeah. Can't wait. Yeah.
跑或者快走和说话。嘿，菲尔。嘿，怎么样？不，我只是，我得做一个咖啡杯。我要打印一个东西，我们要把它做出来。是的。等不及了。是的。
Props are amazing. Props department. Kick and butt. Well, throughout all of this, Dwight is just winding Andy up. They've got that scene in the kitchen. Dwight has clearly done his research. Oh, yeah. After that scene in the kitchen, there's a deleted scene of Andy in the parking lot going off to his dad.
道具太棒了。道具部门。干得漂亮。嗯，在这一切过程中，德怀特只是在激怒安迪。他们在厨房里有那场戏。德怀特显然做了功课。哦，是的。在那场厨房戏之后，有一个删减片段是安迪在停车场对他爸爸发火。
Like, I died, Dad, I'm going to get him. Like, he's like so mad. One of my favorite scenes is the one with Dwight at his desk where he's got all this merch. There's like a pennant hanging from the ceiling. And then he reaches into his drawer. and he gets out a Cornell bobblehead. Yeah. And Andy loses it.
就像，我死了，爸爸，我要抓住他。就像，他太生气了。我最喜欢的场景之一是德怀特在办公桌前，他有所有的周边。天花板上挂着一面三角旗。然后他伸手进抽屉。拿出了一个康奈尔大学的摇头娃娃。是的。安迪崩溃了。
He's like, that's big red bear. Well, I has Phil Shea if that was a real Cornell bobblehead or if we had to make it. And he said it was real. Throughout all these years of the show, because Andy had gone to school at Cornell, he made contacts at the school, particularly the Cornell bookstore. And that is where he got the bobblehead. He said Claudia, Sandra, Peggy, and Patricia are the ladies at Cornell that would always help him out whenever we had a storyline that required some Cornell merch. There's going to be a really good one coming up, and I can't wait to share it in a future episode.
他说，那是大红熊。嗯，我问了菲尔·谢那是不是一个真正的康奈尔摇头娃娃，还是我们必须制作的。他说那是真的。在剧集播出的这些年里，因为安迪在康奈尔上过学，他与学校建立了联系，特别是康奈尔书店。那就是他得到摇头娃娃的地方。他说克劳迪娅、桑德拉、佩吉和帕特里夏是康奈尔的女士们，每当我们有需要康奈尔周边的故事线时，她们总是会帮他。接下来会有一个非常好的，我迫不及待想在未来的一集里分享它。
Thank you, ladies. I love that Phil had all his people. He had all his people everywhere. Well, I have a little thing to share about that Cornell bobblehead as well. So it was not the first choice. What was the first choice? So to ratchet andy up, Dwight was going to have. his cell phone ringtone be the Cornell fight song.
谢谢你们，女士们。我喜欢菲尔有他的人脉。他到处都有他的人脉。嗯，关于那个康奈尔摇头娃娃，我也有点东西要分享。所以它不是第一选择。第一选择是什么？为了激怒安迪，德怀特本打算让他的手机铃声是康奈尔的校歌。
Ooh, that's a good idea. Yeah. But then when they heard it, it just didn't quite work in the moment. It was just like too much setup. And so they felt like the bobblehead was just like this quick, like, boom, I now have the Cornell merch on my desk. Well, I like the personal connection to Angela and the bobbleheads as well. Side by side.
哦，那是个好主意。是的。但当他们听到它时，它在那个时刻不太合适。感觉铺垫太多了。所以他们觉得摇头娃娃就像那种快速的，砰，我现在桌上有康奈尔周边了。嗯，我也喜欢他和安吉拉以及摇头娃娃之间的个人联系。并排在一起。
Yes. So I like that choice for that reason. Well, it almost was give my regards to Davy, which is the Cornell fight song playing on Dwight's cell phone. You know the scene where Andy confronts Dwight outside of the bathroom? Mm-hmm. And Dwight starts asking Andy what Acapella group he should join at Cornell. The Harmoniacs are the Dore Migos. Yes. I looked it up.
是的。所以我喜欢那个选择，原因就在这里。嗯，它差点就是《向戴维致敬》，那是德怀特手机上播放的康奈尔校歌。你知道安迪在洗手间外质问德怀特的场景吗？嗯哼。德怀特开始问安迪他应该在康奈尔加入哪个阿卡贝拉组合。和谐者还是多雷米戈斯？是的。我查过了。
Mm-hmm. According to the Cornell Acapella Advisory Council, there is a Cornell, Acapella Advisory Council. There is a Cornell! Acapella Advisory Council. Amazing. There are not any current acapella groups with those names, but I'm not sure about when we filmed. Aca what? Aca, let me tell you.
嗯哼。根据康奈尔阿卡贝拉咨询委员会，有一个康奈尔阿卡贝拉咨询委员会。有一个康奈尔！阿卡贝拉咨询委员会。太神奇了。目前没有任何阿卡贝拉组合叫那些名字，但我不太确定我们拍摄的时候。阿卡什么？阿卡，让我告诉你。
Veda said that Rain was improvising quite a bit in this moment. Oh. Some was scripted, and then he just started going off. I see. Yes. And also, Anthony shared that he pitched that Stanley should be the first person to come out of the bathroom to kind of throw Andy off. Because Andy's so ready. And then Stanley comes out and he's like, and then he has to get his energy back up for Dwight.
维达说雷恩在这一刻即兴发挥了很多。哦。有些是剧本里的，然后他只是开始发挥了。我明白了。是的。而且，安东尼分享说他提议斯坦利应该是第一个从洗手间出来的人，以此来打乱安迪。因为安迪准备得太充分了。然后斯坦利出来，他说，然后他不得不重新振作起来对付德怀特。
I love that little moment. Great detail. All of this is going to lead to a delicious scene in the conference room because Andy informs Dwight, guess who is conducting your interview? He's contacted Cornell and he's going to do the interview. Yeah. And Dwight's like, bring it on. I love this conference room scene so much.
我喜欢那个小瞬间。很棒的细节。所有这些都将导致会议室里一场精彩的戏，因为安迪通知德怀特，猜猜是谁在主持你的面试？他联系了康奈尔，他要亲自面试。是的。德怀特说，放马过来吧。我太喜欢这个会议室场景了。
I love it so much. Dave shared that this conference room scene between Dwight and Andy was his first day of filming. What? Yes. And he loved that because it was so contained, right? Oh, my gosh, yes. Right? And he said it was about a 10 to 11 page scene. That's a huge scene. Yes, a lot of people asked, was this scripted or improvised? It was almost all scripted. It was almost all scripted, but Veda said that they did let it. Rayne and Ed really play around, especially with the role model name pitches. And these guys kept
我太喜欢了。戴夫分享说，德怀特和安迪之间的这场会议室戏是他拍摄的第一天。什么？是的。他喜欢那样，因为它非常封闭，对吧？天哪，是的。对吧？他说这是一场大约10到11页的戏。那是一场巨大的戏。是的，很多人问，这是剧本写的还是即兴的？几乎全是剧本写的。几乎全是剧本写的，但维达说他们确实让雷恩和埃德玩得很开心，特别是在角色模型名字的提议上。而这些人一直
laughing. They were breaking so hard in the scene. In the end, Dwight says his role models are Dane Cook, Jack Bauer, and Eli Whitney, but in the script they're different. And there's many takes of these names being different. But there was one big part of this scene that was improvised, and Anthony talks about it. It's so good. That scene that we had in the conference room where they were, the double interview, as it were, that was always, like, had always been in there as a fun scene for the two of them to square off at the end of that episode. I do remember there was a moment where it was either Rain or Ed started pulling the table, and I was just like, oh, we've got to do that more. So I talked to Dave, Dave Rogers, who was directing his first episode of The Office, and he's directed a thousand things since because he's freaking amazing.
在笑。他们在这一幕里笑场太严重了。最后，德怀特说他的榜样是戴恩·库克、杰克·鲍尔和伊莱·惠特尼，但在剧本里他们是不同的。这些名字有许多不同的拍摄版本。但这一幕有一个很大的部分是即兴的，安东尼谈到了它。太棒了。我们在会议室里的那场戏，双重面试，那一直，一直都在那里，作为他们两个在这一集结尾对决的有趣场景。我确实记得有一个时刻，要么是雷恩要么是埃德开始拉桌子，我当时就想，哦，我们必须多做那个。所以我跟戴夫·罗杰斯谈了，他正在执导他的第一集《办公室》，从那以后他执导了一千件事，因为他太棒了。
I remember talking about it. They've got to just let them play with that table, let them pull it back and forth. Let them struggle with that and see what happens. And I think we got, that was the only take I think we did of that, where Rain just pulls it all the way to the wall. And thanks him for coming. It's just that whole, you know, those characters are all about conflict, all about power shifts. And that whole dynamic just felt, it felt like the right place to end up with those characters. And so that was a nice little bit of improv that we got to enhance on the day.
我记得谈论过它。他们必须让他们玩那张桌子，让他们来回拉。让他们在那上面挣扎，看看会发生什么。我想我们得到了，我想那是我们做的唯一一次拍摄，雷恩直接把它拉到了墙边。并感谢他的到来。这只是整个，你知道，那些角色都是关于冲突，关于权力转移的。而整个动态感觉，感觉像是结束这些角色的正确位置。所以那是一个很好的即兴表演，我们在当天得到了加强。
I feel like Dave must have been so excited after this first shoot day. Yeah. To get that table tugging moment, to get this whole scene, these guys are so good in it. Yeah. He had to have been fired up. You would think so. I mean, the biggest stuff was ahead of him, but at least he had that first day in the conference room. Well, you know, it's interesting Dave shared with me.
我觉得戴夫在拍摄第一天后一定很兴奋。是的。得到那个拉桌子的时刻，得到整场戏，这些人演得太好了。是的。他一定很激动。你会这么想。我的意思是，最大的事情还在后面，但至少他在会议室有了第一天。嗯，你知道，很有趣的是戴夫跟我分享的。
The last thing we shot for this episode was the Halloween cold open. That was the last day of shooting. Oh, wow. Yeah. He said we needed time to get all those costumes. and everything organized. Yeah. Should we talk about what's going on with Jim and Pam during all of this now?
我们为这一集拍摄的最后一件事是万圣节的冷开场。那是拍摄的最后一天。哦，哇。是的。他说我们需要时间来整理所有的服装和一切。是的。我们现在应该谈谈吉姆和帕姆在这一切过程中发生了什么吗？
Yes. So we know that they're going to have lunch with Jim's brothers, but what we find out is that Pam gets to the restaurant early. Yeah. She wants to do a prank. Because she wants them to like her. Yeah. She's like going to be the fun sister-in-law. Jenna, do you have a guest star breakdown?
是的。所以我们知道他们要和吉姆的兄弟们吃午饭，但我们发现帕姆提前到了餐厅。是的。她想搞个恶作剧。因为她想让他们喜欢她。是的。她想成为那个有趣的嫂子。珍娜，你有客串演员的详细资料吗？
You know I do. Pete Halpert was played by Tug Coker and Tom Helpert was played by Blake Roper. Robbins. They were super tall. Very tall. There's the reason for that. John Krasinski has two very tall brothers in real life, and they thought this would be a fun nod to his family. Yeah. I was able to get in touch with Tug, by the way, and oh my gosh, I could not love this guy more. I mean, we had such a fun time shooting together, and I had so much fun reminiscing with him about this. He told me that the audition notice for this episode, it said it was looking for. actors who were six foot one or taller, preferably with brown hair, but it did not reveal that you
你知道我有。皮特·哈尔珀特由塔格·科克饰演，汤姆·哈尔珀特由布莱克·罗珀·罗宾斯饰演。他们超级高。非常高。这是有原因的。约翰·卡拉辛斯基在现实生活中确实有两个非常高的兄弟，他们认为这对他的家庭来说是一个有趣的致敬。是的。顺便说一句，我联系上了塔格，天哪，我不能更爱这个家伙了。我的意思是，我们一起拍摄玩得很开心，我和他一起回忆这些非常有趣。他告诉我，这一集的试镜通知上说，它正在寻找身高6英尺1英寸或更高的演员，最好是棕色头发，但它没有透露你
would be playing Jim Halpert's brother. Huh. And when he got to the audition, he said, first of all, he's six foot five. And when he got to the audition, Allison Jones said, you look like you could play John Krasinski's brother. That's what she said. And he was like, oh, I'm going to be playing a helper. Yeah.
将扮演吉姆·哈尔珀特的兄弟。嗯。当他去试镜时，他说，首先，他身高6英尺5英寸。当他去试镜时，艾莉森·琼斯说，你看上去就像能演约翰·卡拉辛斯基的兄弟。她就是这么说的。他当时想，哦，我要演一个哈尔珀特。是的。
That was his first clue. he read with Allison's associate Ben Harris, and the next day he got a call that he'd gotten the part. Well, I definitely felt like these guys looked like they could be John's brothers. And you know, John's brothers in real life are super tall. They're like 6-8 or something. They're like the tallest family. Isn't John the short one? Yes.
那是他的第一个线索。他与艾莉森的合伙人本·哈里斯对戏，第二天他就接到电话说他得到了这个角色。嗯，我绝对觉得这些人看起来像是约翰的兄弟。而且你知道，约翰现实生活中的兄弟超级高。他们大概有6英尺8英寸左右。他们就像最高的家庭。约翰不是那个矮个子吗？是的。
And John is 6-3. Yeah, and he's the shorty. That is so crazy. Well, Tug said, here's a thing that happens when you're a really tall actor. you usually have to bring your own clothes. Listen, Tug, that's what happens when you're a really short actor, too. Angela can relate. He said that is his own suit, and those are his own shoes.
约翰身高6英尺3英寸。是的，他是矮个子。这太疯狂了。嗯，塔格说，当你是一个非常高的演员时，会发生一件事：你通常得自带衣服。听着，塔格，当你是一个非常矮的演员时，也会发生这种情况。安吉拉深有同感。他说那是他自己的西装，那是他自己的鞋子。
I believe it. He's pretty sure that Blake wore his own clothes in the scene as well. So you know this first scene at the restaurant, Angela, where Pam has met them early, and she's pitching her idea for what the prank could be. She says her ring, she put it in her little apron, she left it, She's going to throw another girl under the bus. This whole drama, she lost her engagement ring. And they're like, oh, we have a better idea.
我相信。他很确定布莱克在这一幕里也穿了自己的衣服。所以你知道餐厅里的第一场戏，安吉拉，帕姆提前见到了他们，她正在推销她关于恶作剧的想法。她说她的戒指，她把它放在她的小围裙里，她把它落下了，她要陷害另一个女孩。这整场戏，她丢了订婚戒指。他们说，哦，我们有个更好的主意。
Their idea is that they're going to dog Pam about her career choice as an artist. Yeah, and they said, let's do the same thing we did to Jim's girlfriend in high school. What the heck, guys? What is your pattern here? Oh, our bit is we make the girls that Jim's dating feel crappy about themselves. I know. What the heck? I know.
他们的主意是他们要嘲讽帕姆作为艺术家的职业选择。是的，他们说，让我们做和我们在高中时对吉姆的女朋友做的一样的事。搞什么鬼，伙计们？你们的模式是什么？哦，我们的套路是我们让吉姆约会的女孩对自己感觉很糟糕。我知道。搞什么鬼？我知道。
They said in the DVD commentary that they wanted Jim's brothers to be bad at pranking. Like, they're like the less sophisticated prankers of the family. Right. Jim is better at pranking. They're kind of lame at it. So most of this stuff was scripted in the restaurant. We did not have a lot of time, actually, to play around. But Tug reminded me that we did improvise the very end of this scene.
他们在DVD评论音轨里说，他们想让吉姆的兄弟们不擅长恶作剧。就像，他们是家里不太老练的恶作剧者。对。吉姆更擅长恶作剧。他们在这方面有点逊。所以大部分内容在餐厅里都是剧本写的。其实我们没有太多时间去发挥。但塔格提醒我，我们确实即兴表演了这一幕的最后部分。
He said, Jenna, I'm pretty sure you improvised that line. So not the ring thing then. And then the two of them are like, no, no, no, no, this is better, this is better. And I checked the script and he's right. The scene had actually been meant to end sooner. That sounds like you in real life, by the way. That sounds like something you would say. Maybe so.
他说，珍娜，我很确定你即兴说了那句台词。所以不是戒指的事。然后他们两个说，不，不，不，不，这个更好，这个更好。我查了剧本，他是对的。这一幕本来应该更早结束的。顺便说一句，这听起来很像现实生活中的你。这听起来像你会说的话。也许吧。
I feel like we've ordered lunch together and I've gone back and forth about an appetizer and you've said, so not the dip then. We're not doing the dip. Just to clarify. Well, Dave shared that you guys filmed this restaurant scene the day after Labor Day. Oh. Tuesday in September. I thought that was a fun little detail to know.
我觉得我们一起点过午餐，我一直在纠结开胃菜，而你说，所以不是蘸酱吗？我们不点蘸酱。澄清一下。嗯，戴夫分享说你们是在劳动节后的第二天拍摄的这场餐厅戏。哦。九月的星期二。我觉得这是一个有趣的细节。
And Kyle, the locations manager, said that this restaurant was called E-third. Mm-hmm. And it was on the east side of downtown L.A. They were really trying to get this area to double as Brooklyn where Pam was attending Pratt. I think they did a good job. Yeah. Well, the restaurant was a steakhouse. Mm-hmm.
而凯尔，外景经理，说这家餐厅叫E-third。嗯哼。它在洛杉矶市中心的东区。他们真的试图让这个区域作为帕姆就读普拉特的布鲁克林的替身。我觉得他们做得很好。是的。嗯，这家餐厅是一家牛排馆。嗯哼。
And in the next scene where you see that we're eating, after Jim has arrived, we got to just pick off the menu. Oh, so you're really. eating the restaurant food? Yeah. Oh, that's so lucky. I know. Oh, that's cool. Well, Tug said he remembers it very clearly because it was the very first time he had to eat in a scene. And when they gave him the menu, he thought his character would order steak at a steakhouse. And that John Krasinski said, oh, dude, you're going to regret that choice. You're going to be eating cold steak for several hours. And Tug was like, what do you mean? I'm going to eat steak. And that's what my character would eat, and he said, John ordered a salad and like a little protein on the side. And that's what I ordered
在下一幕你看到我们在吃饭时，在吉姆到达之后，我们得从菜单上点菜。哦，所以你们真的在吃餐厅的食物？是的。哦，那太幸运了。我知道。哦，那很酷。嗯，塔格说他记得很清楚，因为这是他第一次必须在戏里吃东西。当他们给他菜单时，他以为他的角色会在牛排馆点牛排。而约翰·卡拉辛斯基说，哦，伙计，你会后悔那个选择的。你会吃几个小时的冷牛排。塔格说，你什么意思？我要吃牛排。这就是我的角色会吃的，他说，约翰点了一份沙拉和一点蛋白质。那就是我点的
as well. Well, Tug said that his concern about ordering a salad was that he didn't want any food to fall on him during the scene. He was like, this is the first time I'm eating and acting. I think steak, I can get it on the fork. I can get it in my mouth. Well, steak is definitely easier to eat than salad. Well, Tug pointed out to me, and I didn't notice it the first time I watched it. But he said it's burned in his brain because this is the scene that was on his acting reel for years and years. So at 12 minutes, 25 seconds, John is struggling with this bite of salad. You can see it. I saw that too.
一样。嗯，塔格说他担心点沙拉是因为他不想在拍摄过程中有任何食物掉在他身上。他说，这是我第一次吃东西和演戏。我想牛排，我可以把它叉在叉子上。我可以把它放进嘴里。嗯，牛排绝对比沙拉好嚼。嗯，塔格向我指出，我第一次看的时候没注意到。但他说是刻在他脑子里的，因为这是他多年来演艺简历上的场景。所以在12分25秒，约翰正在和那口沙拉作斗争。你可以看出来。我也看到了。
He's having a very hard time getting this piece of lettuce in his mouth. And then, if you watch closely, one leaf misses his mouth and falls into his lap, which was exactly Tug's fear that if Tug had been eating salad, he would have missed his mouth. He was then glad he had ordered that steak and had to eat it for hours. John, as I rewatch that, I thought, that's a really big aggressive bite of lettuce. Like, he really went for it. He did. You know, sometimes when you're eating salad in a scene, you don't realize what you've got on the fork
他很难把那片生菜放进嘴里。然后，如果你仔细看，一片叶子没进嘴里，掉在了他的腿上，这正是塔格担心的，如果塔格当时在吃沙拉，他也会错过嘴。他后来很高兴他点了牛排，并且不得不吃上几个小时。约翰，当我重看的时候，我想，那是一口非常大且激进的生菜。就像，他真的拼了。他确实。你知道，有时当你在戏里吃沙拉时，你没意识到叉子上有什么
and then you just have to commit to it. And that was on Tugs Real. So he watched it over and over. Over and over again, he watched that piece of lettuce fall. So, you know, their dinner starts out pretty sweet, right? Jim is holding up a photo of his niece. Mm-hmm. Right?
然后你只能硬着头皮吃下去。而那就在塔格的简历上。所以他一遍又一遍地看。一遍又一遍，他看着那片生菜掉下来。所以，你知道，他们的晚餐开始得相当甜蜜，对吧？吉姆举着一张他侄女的照片。嗯哼。对吧？
Yeah. So you feel like this is going to be nice. It's pre-prank. The prank hasn't started yet. Prank hasn't started yet. The photo that John is holding up is our set medic, Patrice King's daughter. Aw. Yeah, Phil shared that.
是的。所以你觉得这会很美好。这是恶作剧前。恶作剧还没开始。恶作剧还没开始。约翰举着的那张照片是我们片场医护人员帕特里斯·金的女儿。啊。是的，菲尔分享了。
Phil would do that, you guys. This scene also has the moment where all of us at the end of the scene give a look to camera. And it's such a cool moment. Tug said he remembers Dave Roger giving him the direction to check in with the camera throughout the scene. and this was like so crazy to him because, you know, he'd never been in a project where you were allowed to look down the lens like that. But I love this moment. I love the look that he gives the camera and you just go around the table and we all give this little look to camera about this prank that is not going well. Not going well.
菲尔会那样做的，伙计们。这一幕也有我们所有人在这场戏结束时看向镜头的时刻。那是一个非常酷的时刻。塔格说他记得戴夫·罗杰斯给他的指示，要在整场戏中与镜头互动。这对他来说太疯狂了，因为，你知道，他从来没参与过允许你那样直视镜头的项目。但我喜欢这个时刻。我喜欢他给镜头的那个眼神，你绕着桌子走，我们都对这个进展不顺利的恶作剧给了镜头一个小眼神。进展不顺利。
Dave talked about it a little bit. He said he wanted the brothers to look to camera to just give that subtle hint that their mannerisms were similar to Jim. That they would check in like that. At 8 minutes 33 seconds, Pete gives a solo look to camera. Mm-hmm. And at 12 minutes, 31 seconds, Tom gives a gym kind of shrug to camera. I loved that one. I thought that was so good.
戴夫谈到了一点。他说他想让兄弟们看向镜头，只是为了给出一个微妙的暗示，他们的举止和吉姆很像。他们会那样互动。在8分33秒，皮特给了镜头一个单独的眼神。嗯哼。在12分31秒，汤姆给了镜头一个吉姆式的耸肩。我喜欢那个。我觉得那太棒了。
Well, as this prank continues, it is really getting under Pam's skin. Like, she is getting very flustered. I think particularly when he suggests that she pay the bill by drawing on the napkin. Oh. Jenna, if you need a boost. Listen to the DVD commentary because Veda said she was so impressed with your performance. Aw. She said, you know, the way this was scripted is tough because Pam has to want to be on board to be pranked.
嗯，随着恶作剧的继续，它真的让帕姆很不舒服。就像，她变得非常慌乱。我想特别是当他建议她通过在餐巾纸上画画来付账时。哦。珍娜，如果你需要鼓励。听听DVD评论音轨，因为维达说她对你的表演印象深刻。啊。她说，你知道，这样写剧本很艰难，因为帕姆必须想要参与被恶作剧。
But then also start clocking like, hey, that's kind of a dig. Okay, you're kind of going too far. And she said, Jenna did such an amazing job. It was really sweet. Veda was showing you some love. That's really sweet. Well, it was kind of a fine line because everything that Veda said, part of this storyline was also meant to further Pam's insecurity about the idea of being an artist.
但随后也开始意识到，嘿，那话有点刻薄。好吧，你有点太过分了。她说，珍娜做得太棒了。真的很贴心。维达在向你示好。这真的很甜。嗯，这界限有点微妙，因为维达所说的一切，这段剧情的一部分也是为了加深帕姆对自己作为艺术家的不安全感。
Oh. And, you know, because this is something that she wants, but Pam is not a person with a lot of certainty all the time. And this was supposed to play on that. It was a lot for Pam to go to art school. It really was. Yeah. And so this is meant to kind of discourage her momentum.
哦。而且，你知道，因为这是她想要的，但帕姆并不是一个一直很有自信的人。这本该利用这一点。对帕姆来说，去上艺术学校压力很大。确实如此。是的，所以这旨在某种程度上打击她的积极性。
Oh, that makes me sad. Yeah. I know, I know. I have to say, it was so nice reconnecting with Tug about these scenes. You know, he said he's still in touch with Blake. He still gets recognized for having been on the show. Something he told me that I thought was really special was that the day this episode aired, Dave Rogers called him personally, complimented his performance, and told him,
哦，这让我很难过。是的。我知道，我知道。我必须说，能和塔格重新联系并谈论这些场景真是太好了。你知道，他说他仍然和布莱克保持联系。他仍然因为出演过这部剧而被认出来。他告诉我的一件事，我觉得非常特别，那就是这一集播出的那天，戴夫·罗杰斯亲自打电话给他，称赞了他的表演，并告诉他，
hey, I wanted you to know that the bulk of the brother's scenes made it into the episode. And so when you see it tonight, it's there. That is so nice. No one does that. That was so nice of Dave. No one does that. And Tug said, you know, I'd done a ton of guest roles. And sometimes you tell your whole family to watch it and they watch it and your whole part has been reduced to one line.
嘿，我想让你知道，兄弟的大部分场景都进入了这一集。所以当你今晚看的时候，它就在那里。那真是太好了。没人会那样做。戴夫真是太好了。没人会那样做。塔格说，你知道，我演过很多客串角色。有时你告诉全家人去看，他们看了，而你的全部戏份却被删减到只剩一句台词。
All the time. He said, so he was so excited. He called his friends and family. And he was like, yes, yes, watch the show. really on it. And the show was a big deal at the time. This was a big deal to him and his friends and family that he had been on it. So Dave Rogers, you are a gem. Tug, thank you so much. I want you guys to know that you can catch him on a show called Now We're Talking. It is a scripted comedy series and he co-created it, produced it, and stars in it. And it was nominated for a WGA award.
一直都是这样。他说，所以他非常兴奋。他给他的朋友和家人打了电话。他说，是的，是的，看这个节目。真的在上面。而且这个节目在当时是个大事件。对他和他的朋友家人来说，他能出现在节目里是一件大事。所以戴夫·罗杰斯，你真是个宝藏。塔格，非常感谢你。我想让你们知道，你们可以在一个叫《现在我们在谈话》的节目中看到他。这是一部剧本喜剧系列，他参与创作、制作并主演。它还获得了美国编剧工会奖提名。
It's produced by LeBron James and Maverick Carter's Company, Spring Hill. But office fans, if you check it out, you might see some office alums on there. They've got Malcolm Barrett and Andy Buckley pop up on the show. Nice. So definitely check it out because this guy is amazing. Tug, thank you so much. So we finish out this Jim and Pam storyline. They're leaving the restaurant.
它由勒布朗·詹姆斯和马弗里克·卡特的制作公司Spring Hill制作。但是办公室的粉丝们，如果你去看看，你可能会在上面看到一些办公室的校友。他们有马尔科姆·巴雷特和安迪·巴克利在节目中客串。不错。所以一定要去看看，因为这家伙太棒了。塔格，非常感谢你。所以我们结束了吉姆和帕姆的这段剧情。他们正在离开餐厅。
The two of them are walking down the street. And Pam's like, that's not exactly how I had that going. Yeah. Like I had a whole different prank, and she tells it to him. And then Jenna, Veda shared that you ad-libbed the end. The line about him being bald? You ad-libed. How about we prank him on Thanksgiving about him being bald?
他们俩走在街上。帕姆说，那不是我预想的那样。是的。就像我有一个完全不同的恶作剧，她告诉了他。然后珍娜，维达分享说你即兴发挥了结尾。关于他秃头的台词？你即兴发挥的。我们感恩节对他秃头的事搞个恶作剧怎么样？
That was all you. I was really proud of that line. I thought that was funny. Yeah, it was really funny. So you had some improvs in this one, lady. I did. I really did. Now I think we should wrap up this Michael and Holly's storyline because they've arrived at Holly's
那全是你。我真的很为那句台词感到自豪。我觉得那很有趣。是的，那真的很有趣。所以你在这集里有一些即兴表演，女士。我确实有。我真的有。现在我认为我们应该结束迈克尔和霍莉的这段剧情，因为他们已经到达了霍莉的
charming little house in Nashua. I know. Anthony said in the script he wanted it to be a basement apartment. Oh. But he was like, but we don't really have basement apartments here. So they found this little house in Angelino Heights. Oh. Isn't it so cute? I thought it was so cute. It brought up a lot of questions for me, though. Okay. If Holly was in Nashua and she had to move her whole life and all her stuff and get rid of her house slash apartment that she had been living in and moved to Scranton. She was only in Scranton for, I think, like, less than two months. And now she has to move all the way back. And it was kind of breaking my heart for her.
纳舒厄迷人的小房子。我知道。安东尼在剧本里说他想要一个地下室公寓。哦。但他当时说，但我们这里真的没有地下室公寓。所以他们在安吉利诺高地找到了这个小房子。哦。它不可爱吗？我觉得它太可爱了。不过，这对我来说引发了很多问题。好吧。如果霍莉在纳舒厄，她不得不搬走她的整个生活和所有东西，并处理掉她一直住的房子或公寓，然后搬到斯克兰顿。她在斯克兰顿只待了，我想，不到两个月。现在她不得不搬回原处。这让我为她感到心碎。
I was glad they picked a cute location because I was thinking, oh, my gosh, she just left this city. But then I thought it tracks that she would know where to get a cute place if she was from there. Right. Maybe it's even her old place. Maybe it is. It's super cute. Super cute. Also, per Dave, they were really stressed about losing light, and they were going to be losing some of the crew because they were going to leave to go film the Jim and Pam proposal scene with Ken Quappas.
我很高兴他们选了一个可爱的地点，因为我在想，天哪，她刚离开这个城市。但后来我想，如果她是那里的人，她知道去哪里找个可爱的地方也是合理的。对吧。也许那甚至是她的老地方。也许是。它超级可爱。超级可爱。另外，据戴夫说，他们非常担心失去光线，而且他们将失去一些工作人员，因为他们要离开去和肯·夸帕斯拍摄吉姆和帕姆的求婚场景。
Yeah, so we would do this sometimes. We filmed the Jim Pam proposal during this episode's week of filming. Right, because they had to build the whole thing. Sometimes the schedule just got wonky like that. So Dave was really on a time crunch here to get this filmed. Well, Michael decides he's not going to stay. He had planned to stay for the weekend. I guess to help her unpack, it seems pretty clear that they're going to break up.
是的，所以我们有时会这样做。我们在这一集的拍摄周期间拍摄了吉姆和帕姆的求婚。对，因为他们必须搭建整个场景。有时时间表就是会变得很奇怪。所以戴夫在这里拍摄的时间非常紧迫。好吧，迈克尔决定他不留下来。他原计划留下来过周末。我想是为了帮她拆包，看起来很明显他们要分手了。
Yeah. Because of the seven-hour drive that's really a five-hour drive. Four and a half. They could have totally done it. They could have done it. I wanted to go into the TV and tell them. But Anthony said that he wrote dialogue here for them saying goodbye and how, well, maybe I'll see you or maybe we'll go and this and that. And then in the moment, Amy and Steve just did this really big, long, lingering hug. And Dave was like, that's it. Yeah. They don't need to have the dialogue. That hug tells you everything. We had a lot of mail. Oh, yeah? From Chris W. Chelsea C. Hanlon H. And many others. Just asking.
是的。因为那七小时的车程实际上是五小时的车程。四个半小时。他们完全可以做到。他们本可以做到的。我想走进电视告诉他们。但安东尼说，他在这里为他们写了告别的对话，比如，好吧，也许我会见到你，或者也许我们会去等等。然后在那一刻，艾米和史蒂夫只是做了一个非常大、很长的、留恋的拥抱。戴夫当时说，就是这样。是的。他们不需要对话。那个拥抱说明了一切。我们收到了很多邮件。哦，是吗？来自克里斯·W、切尔西·C、汉伦·H。还有许多其他人。只是问了
a couple of questions. Number one, how was Michael planning to get back to Scranton if he and Holly hadn't broken up? Right. Neither of them have a car. That was the other thing. Did Holly not bring a car to Nashua? What'd she do with her car? Did she leave it in Scranton? I don't know. They didn't tow it. No. I noticed. I looked for it. Poor Holly has just gotten dropped off with all her stuff. mattress in like, you know, plastic wrap. No one is helping her unpack and she has no car. And she's dressed for work. Yeah. That's how we leave Holly and Nashua. I know. This whole storyline ends with such an amazing scene of Michael and Daryl in the car, driving back. Dave was really stressed because, like you said, they were losing light. Yeah, he said Randall, our camera operator,
几个问题。第一，如果迈克尔和霍莉没有分手，他打算怎么回斯克兰顿？对。他们俩都没有车。那是另一件事。霍莉没带车去纳舒厄吗？她怎么处理她的车了？她把它留在斯克兰顿了吗？我不知道。他们没把它拖走。不。我注意到了。我找过它。可怜的霍莉刚带着她所有的东西被放下。床垫还在塑料包装里。没人帮她拆包，她也没有车。而且她还穿着工作服。是的。这就是我们离开纳舒厄时的霍莉。我知道。整个剧情以迈克尔和达里尔在车里开车回去的精彩场景结束。戴夫非常紧张，因为正如你所说，他们正在失去光线。是的，他说兰德尔，我们的摄像师，
was going, come on, we got to get this now. We got to get it now. The sun was setting, but didn't it make for such a beautiful backdrop? Yes. It just meant that they didn't get a lot of takes. They had to nail it. Anthony said he loved that it was getting dark because you really got the sense that they spent the whole day together. I liked that, too. Dave told me this is his favorite scene from the episode.
当时说，快点，我们现在得拍这个。我们现在得拍到它。太阳正在下山，但这难道没有形成一个美丽的背景吗？是的。这只是意味着他们没有很多拍摄机会。他们必须一次成功。安东尼说他喜欢天色变暗，因为你真的能感觉到他们在一起度过了整整一天。我也喜欢那样。戴夫告诉我这是他这一集中最喜欢的场景。
Anthony said the same thing. Yeah, Anthony was very excited because this was his pitch and his idea. He talks about it right here. Yeah, this is my first ever episode of television that was really really. written and got on to TV. So it holds a very near and dear place in my heart, this one. All the stuff with the breakup. And oh, the thing with, oh, my God, of course, the scene at the end where Michael's singing the blues, that's a special moment for me in particular because I do remember pitching that in the room. And it's one of those things as a writer. So many things you pitch,
安东尼也说了同样的话。是的，安东尼非常兴奋，因为这是他的提议和想法。他就在这里谈到了它。是的，这是我写的第一部真正写出来并登上电视的电视剧。所以它在我心中占据了一个非常亲近和珍贵的位置，这一集。所有关于分手的戏份。还有，哦，天哪，当然，最后迈克尔唱蓝调的场景，那对我个人来说是一个特别的时刻，因为我确实记得在房间里提出过那个想法。这是作为编剧的事情之一。你提出的很多事情，
they might end up in other people's scripts, but they might end up in your script. And you're just trying to tell the story the best way you can. And every once in a while you get a situation where something you pitch is in your script and it ends up being on the show and you feel like, oh, that's It's amazing. So that whole blues moment at the end when Michael Scott just doesn't get it, but still has the cathartic moment he needs at the end of that. I remember pitching that in the room and thinking, oh, that'll be fun to get to do. And then I got to write the episode. And then I got to watch it happen.
它们可能最终出现在别人的剧本里，但它们也可能出现在你的剧本里。你只是在尽你所能讲好故事。偶尔你会遇到这种情况，你提出的东西在你的剧本里，最终出现在节目中，你会觉得，哦，那太棒了。所以最后那个蓝调时刻，当迈克尔·斯科特只是不明白，但仍然在最后有了他需要的宣泄时刻。我记得在房间里提出那个想法，并想，哦，能做那个会很有趣。然后我写了那一集。然后我看着它发生了。
And it was getting dark. And it was just a perfect little moment for us. And I just remember feeling like I have the best job in the world. I know those scenes. Well, I just love that. There is something so special about seeing your idea, fully realized. And I just love that he shared that. Well, lady, we have one last scene.
而且天色变暗了。这对我们来说是一个完美的时刻。我只记得感觉我拥有世界上最好的工作。我知道那些场景。好吧，我只是喜欢那样。看到你的想法完全实现，有一种非常特别的感觉。我只是喜欢他分享了这一点。好吧，女士，我们还有最后一个场景。
We do. You know, we don't really ever find out exactly how this Cornell interview application thing wraps up. I assume he doesn't get in, but that was never really the point. The point of this storyline was really Angela. Angela was the point. This was Dwight was performing for her. Right. And he's winding Andy up because he is jealous.
我们有。你知道，我们从来没有真正弄清楚这个康奈尔面试申请的事情到底是怎么结束的。我假设他没进去，但这从来都不是重点。这段剧情的重点实际上是安吉拉。安吉拉才是重点。这是德怀特在为她表演。对。他在激怒安迪，因为他嫉妒。
That's right. Well, there was a hole runner. There were scenes between Angela and Andy where Andy's all worked up and Angela's trying to calm him down and then Angela goes to Dwight and it's like, what the heck? Here's one of those deleted scenes.
没错。好吧，有一个完整的副线。安吉拉和安迪之间有场景，安迪非常激动，安吉拉试图让他冷静下来，然后安吉拉去找德怀特，就像，搞什么鬼？这是其中一个被删减的场景。
Why are you doing this to Andy? You once told me that Andy and I had different strengths. Well, he can't do what I can do. I can get into Cornell, but he doesn't know how to make food and shelter from a golden retriever. Even if you do somehow get
你为什么要对安迪这样做？你曾经告诉我，安迪和我有不同的优势。好吧，他做不到我能做的事。我可以进入康奈尔，但他不知道如何用金毛猎犬制作食物和住所。即使你以某种方式进入了
in. That's not going to make me leave Andy. No, but it'll make you respect him less. Yes, that's true. Oh, I wish that it stayed in. I know, because Dwight does get what he wants, right? Yeah. I think Andy unravels in front of Angela, and whether Dwight gets into Cornell or not, she didn't care for it.
那也不会让我离开安迪。不，但这会让你更不尊重他。是的，那是真的。哦，我希望它能保留下来。我知道，因为德怀特确实得到了他想要的，对吧？是的。我想安迪在安吉拉面前崩溃了，无论德怀特是否进入康奈尔，她都不在乎。
No, not at all. And now we have this tag where Andy's going to pay back Dwight. But of course, it's just so embarrassing. In fact, at 20 minutes, 51 seconds is one of my most popular memes. What, when you're rolling your eyes? Yes. Andy walks in dressed as a farmer with no shirt on and beats, and my character rolls her eyes and then puts her head into her hand. Oh, we had a fan question. People wanted to know, did Rain actually take a bite out of a beat at the end of the episode? Yes, he did, and that was improvised.
不，一点也不。现在我们有了这个标签，安迪要报复德怀特。但当然，这太尴尬了。事实上，在20分51秒处是我最受欢迎的表情包之一。什么，当你翻白眼的时候？是的。安迪穿着农民装，没穿衬衫，拿着甜菜走进来，我的角色翻了个白眼，然后把头埋进手里。哦，我们有一个粉丝问题。人们想知道，雷恩在这一集结尾真的咬了一口甜菜吗？是的，他咬了，那是即兴发挥的。
Yes, and Veda said he did it in the last take. Very smart, Rain, if you're going to do it. Yeah, it was scripted that Andy tries to bite the beat and that line about, oh, you're supposed to cook it first. That was in the script. But the button of Dwight being able to bite a beat, that was all rain. All rain, Wilson. You guys, that was employee transfer. Yes. And we want to give a huge thanks to all the people who helped gather information on this episode.
是的，维达说他在最后一次拍摄时做的。非常聪明，雷恩，如果你要这样做的话。是的，剧本里写的是安迪试图咬甜菜，还有那句关于，哦，你应该先煮熟它。那在剧本里。但是德怀特能够咬甜菜的那个点睛之笔，全靠雷恩。全靠雷恩·威尔逊。你们，那是员工调动。是的。我们要向所有帮助收集这一集信息的人表示衷心的感谢。
It was a bunch of people. Thank you. Thank you to James Carey, Dave Rogers, Elie. Raycraft, Phil Shea, Anthony Farrell, and Tug Corker for sharing your memories. One final shout out for Tug. He and his wife own a wine bar. What? It's Santa Monica, Angela.
那是很多人。谢谢。感谢詹姆斯·凯里、戴夫·罗杰斯、埃利·雷克拉夫特、菲尔·谢伊、安东尼·法雷尔和塔格·科克分享你们的回忆。最后给塔格一个特别的致谢。他和他的妻子拥有一家葡萄酒吧。什么？在圣莫尼卡，安吉拉。
It's called Esther's. He's invited us to come down. Have some wine and cheese with them. Tug, we are there. Right? Well, he and his wife also do a podcast together called The Long Finish. You can find them on Instagram at the Long Finish. Here's what they do.
它叫埃丝特。他邀请我们过去。和他们一起喝点葡萄酒和奶酪。塔格，我们到了。对吧？嗯，他和他的妻子还一起做了一个播客，叫《长余味》。你可以在Instagram上找到他们，账号是The Long Finish。这是他们做的。
they open a bottle of wine and they discuss their life as they work together and raise three kids. He has a three-week-old baby. Tug. Right. Bless your heart. Right. You're in the weeds. They are in the weeds, but they still do this podcast about their life together.
他们打开一瓶酒，讨论他们一起工作和抚养三个孩子的生活。他有一个三周大的婴儿。塔格。对。上帝保佑你的心。对。你陷入了困境。他们陷入了困境，但他们仍然做这个关于他们共同生活的播客。
And Tug, we're coming to have wine with you guys. We sure are. And you guys, if you haven't watched the bloopers for this one, they're a must watch. Go to the DVD box set. They're so good. I'm so jealous. have this one. We got to get it for you. I know. Well, you guys, sometimes life is a highway. And you got to ride it all night long. We'll see you next week. See you next week. And this song
塔格，我们要去和你们一起喝葡萄酒。我们当然会。还有你们，如果你们还没看过这一集的NG片段，它们是必看的。去DVD套装里找。它们太棒了。我好嫉妒。有这个。我们得为你弄到它。我知道。好吧，你们，有时生活就像一条高速公路。你必须整夜骑行。我们下周见。下周见。这首歌
will be in your head forever now. You know it. If you're going my way. All night long. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
现在会永远留在你的脑海里。你知道的。如果你走我的路。整夜。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的第二杯剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratt. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。